bonsoir on est en direct aujourd'hui
pour un événement d'avant Coupe du Monde
la Coupe du monde ça commence dans une
semaine et demie pour les Bleus le
premier match ce sera le 22 novembre et
aujourd'hui on va parler de la liste des
joueurs qui partiront au Qatar et pour
m'accompagner pour en parler je suis
avec Sébastien feras au Figaro salut
Vincent salut à tous bienvenue vous
n'hésitez pas dans les commentaires je
vois que vous êtes déjà nombreux à être
ici n'hésitez pas à nous dire un peu ce
que vous attendez
de Didier Deschamps qui devraient
prendre la parole aux alentours de 20h20
20h30 qui annoncera cette liste et puis
ensuite il y aura une conférence de
presse aux alentours de 21h on vous fera
suivre tout ça bien évidemment vous
diffusera pas parce que c'est TF1 qui
diffuse mais restez avec nous on va tout
analyser on va tout vous dire de ce
qu'on peut voir en tout cas
Sébastien une liste de la Coupe du Monde
on sait c'est compliqué et il faut faire
des choix par définition
aime bien ironiser là-dessus c'est que
aujourd'hui il y aura 67 millions de
sélectionneurs de l'équipe de en France
donc oui c'est compliqué alors ce sera
quand même un petit peu plus facile que
d'habitude entre guillemets parce que ça
sera pas 23 joueurs comme à la coutumée
ce sera 26 en tout cas Didier Deschamps
sélectionner 26 on sait que au début il
était un peu réticent il voulait pas
prendre trop de joueurs avoir trop de
joueurs remplaçants qui manquerait de
temps de jeu finalement il va un petit
peu si résigner pour les raisons qu'on
connaisse c'est-à-dire la forme physique
de certains cadres qui est encore très
incertaine effectivement on verra
effectivement parce que il faut le dire
il y a quand même eu pas mal de blessés
on a déjà Kanté Pogba c'est sûr mieux de
terrain mais on a quand même pas mal
d'incertains donc Karim Benzema par
exemple Rafel Varenne ouais Benzema
Varane alors a priori les nouvelles sont
plutôt bonnes en tout cas pour pour
Benzema pour kimpembe aussi c'est plutôt
rassurant par contre ce qu'on sait c'est
que Benzema ne jouera pas demain avec le
Real Madrid c'est le dernier match du
Real avant avant la Coupe du monde donc
Benzema ne rejouera plus avant avant la
Coupe du monde si jamais il est bien là
normalement il sera en tout cas il sera
dans la liste après on verra comment ça
va évoluer physiquement effectivement il
y a kimpembe il y a varan qui un certain
Mike Meignan aussi deuxième gardien de
l'équipe de France
certains joueurs sont un peu incertains
ils sont pas forcément amenés non plus à
jouer un très grand rôle certains un
petit peu plus donc on va voir il y a
encore quand même pas mal d'incertitudes
quelques minutes de la liste on nous
parle de Olivier Giroud Olivier Giroud
il mérite d'être là le retour d'Olivier
Giroud la place d'Olivier Giroud elle
est assez certaine on a l'impression oui
elle est elle est certaine maintenant de
tout de toutes les infos notamment qu'on
a chez nous au Figaro en tout cas
Olivier Giroud sera en équipe de France
pour la Coupe du Monde il sera là
évidemment il y a eu beaucoup
d'accertitudes parce qu'à l'euro ça a
été un petit peu compliqué notamment sa
relation avec Killian Mbappé qui a été
beaucoup discuté depuis ça va mieux ça
va mieux surtout sur le dernier
rassemblement en septembre où ils sont
mis en entendus hors du terrain et sur
le terrain où là où c'est le plus
important donc oui Giroud sera là il
cartonne avec l'AC Milan il a encore
signé une très grande prestation Ligue
des Champions il y a une semaine
dernière je crois un magnifique but oui
en série a aussi avec l'AC Milan il sera
là pour être un atout plutôt remplaçant
mais il pourrait vraiment un atout sur
des bouts de match avec l'équipe de
France Hitachi qui nous dit Pembe mérite
oui qui PMB censé être automatique pour
lui maintenant les 30 équipes de France
mais ça va dépendre aussi de son état
physique c'est ça ça va entièrement
défendre de son état physique alors sur
le niveau aussi ça a été un petit peu un
petit peu compliqué il a été très
irrégulier avec le avec le PSG même avec
l'équipe de France où il n'a pas
toujours assumé son statut celui d'un
champion du monde quand même on le
rappelle il était déjà là en 2018 sans
être un cadre de cette équipe il a même
porté le brassard il y a quelques mois
avec les Bleus mais effectivement il y a
des incertitudes sur ce sur son physique
et sur une blessure au tendon d'Achille
on sait toujours pas si il va jouer ce
week-end avec le PSG contre Auxerre
c'est quand même une grosse question
parce que si je vous passe ça veut dire
qu'il devra attendre la Coupe du monde
un peu comme Benzema sauf que Kim PMB il
a rejoué qu'un seul match depuis la
mi-septembre donc depuis deux mois donc
il est vraiment à court de forme à court
de rythme donc là effectivement il y a
il y a beaucoup d'interrogations on a
déjà qui nous dit que le moisi il est en
forme que le moisi il parle un peu loin
quand même il part plus loin il avait
quand même appelé en équipe de France là
aussi parce que justement il y avait un
peu une hécatombe donc oui il paraît
effectivement de loin
de tout ce qui de tout ce qui sort sur
le secteur offensif il y aura pas de
grosses surprises il y aura pas de de
petits nouveaux de petites Joker on peut
penser à colomanie mais aussi à Martin
Terrier qui cartonne cette saison avec
Rennes malheureusement il y aura
peut-être pas de place pour eux aussi
parce que le secteur enfantif il est
extrêmement concurrentiel oui alors on
pourrait le voir mais effectivement il y
a des blessés il y a des secteurs où
c'est compliqué au milieu par exemple on
se voit bien mais par contre on attaque
des champs à des nouveaux encore des
problèmes de riches bah finalement oui
il a des problèmes de riche parce que il
y a aucun absent alors il y a eu la
petite incertitude autour de Karim
Benzema qui est plus ou moins effacé
mais pour les autres finalement ça va
bien Antoine Griezmann a retrouvé la
forme et le sourire avec l'Atletico
kunku est bien là Mbappé sera là
Ousmane Dembélé n'a pas de pépin
physique il y a Kingsley coman aussi qui
rétablit qui sera présent donc
finalement tout le monde est plus ou
moins disponible donc ça laisse
se passe on attaque finalement à des
surprises on nous redemande est-ce que
tu as une chance à votre avis
à titre personnel j'aurais même plus
tendance à pencher vers terrier que vers
colomanie mais non franchement je pense
qu'il a aucune chance ce serait une
énorme surprise de prendre un autre
attaquant
on pourrait même penser par exemple la
Moussa Diaby on parle pas trop de lui
mais c'est quand même aussi un habituel
équipe de France il doit avoir sa
quinzaine de sélections aujourd'hui pour
l'instant a priori il sera pas à moins
d'une surprise il marche bien avec avec
les vertus sains donc lui aussi il
pourrait mériter sa place et je pense
qu'il passerait devant un Martin Terrier
par exemple alors on nous dit dans les
commentaires aussi gain Douzi on veut
vraiment plus le voir je sais pas si il
dit plus ou plus le voir il y a une vie
pour le coup il est un peu en sursis il
est sur un peu un siège éjectable un
petit strapontin en fait il est un peu
un peu incertain il est un peu dans dans
ce milieu de terrain on doit y avoir
cinq ou six joueurs alors il y en a
trois sur c'est rabiot de choix mini et
Yusuf Fofana et derrière il y en a qui
se battent un peu pour les dernières
classiques il y a son récipient l'OM
Jordan veritout on peut aussi penser à
peut-être Booba car Camara à Aston Villa
qui était revenu récemment de blessure
qui a joué bientôt cette saison mais qui
est revenu et qui avait déjà qui avait
déjà porté le maillot de l'équipe de
France donc ça va ça va jouer à pas
grand chose et gain Douzi oui peut avoir
il peut tout à fait avoir sa chance il
peut avoir sa chance effectivement alors
vous n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser
vos questions nku nous parle d'un coucou
un coucou à priori ça a l'air assez
sûr qu'il soit pris maintenant oui oui
c'est sûr il sera là c'est pas non plus
un cadre mais apparaît comme un
remplaçant très clair très clairement
identifié en attaque un peu dans le rôle
d'Antoine Griezmann peut-être ou pas
parce que on va le voir aussi on va en
discuter mais selon le schéma tactique
de l'équipe de France ça peut
complètement changer la liste et à
certains joueurs qui risque de souffrir
de du choix que fera Didier Deschamps
sur le plan tactique et on parle d'un
joueur en particulier depuis un moment
aujourd'hui c'est Jonathan close je
m'attends close piston donc il joue dans
un système à 5 donc avec il faut trois
défenseurs centraux et deux pistons donc
des latéraux qui montent en gros un peu
plus haut je vais attendre klos il
pourrait faire les frais justement de ce
de cela c'est ça parce qu'a priori dit
des champs ne serait plus du tout
convaincu par par ce système en trois
cinq deux donc où je n’attends que l'eau
ça a explosé au plus haut niveau avec
Lance et aujourd'hui avec l'OM c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il a été appelé en
équipe de France parce qu'il
correspondait parfaitement à ce système
sauf que si Didier Deschamps abandonne
ce système bah tout de suite la présence
de clos elle est plus du tout évidente
parce qu'il serait dans un poste qui ne
connaît quasiment pas un poste très
différent qui demanderait d'autres
d'autres repères et en plus de ça il a
quand même beaucoup joué avec l'OM on a
vu qu'il était assez fatigué il a un peu
soufflé le chaud et le froid aussi parce
que justement il est fatigué et voilà
c'est un peu lui qui pourrait faire les
frais à ce niveau là et dire des champs
pourraient se rabattre sur des joueurs
un petit peu plus expérimentés dans dans
ce vrai rôle de latérale droit alors on
a pas mal de petits noms qui sortent et
qui sont c'est possible alors la liste
c'est dans quelques instants on a déjà
dit entre 20h20 et 20 entre 20h20 et
20h30 ça ça va arriver on nous parle
d'Alban Lafont Alban Lafont gardien du
FC Nantes jeune très prometteur mais il
y a peut-être aéré au lait devant encore
alors bah on veut pas dire que on a déjà
Lloris ça c'est sûr au niveau des
gardiens Mike Meignan s'il est apte a
priori pour être apte et le troisième
cru c'est Areola ça devrait plutôt être
Areola qui a une légère longueur
d'avance après Alban à fond aussi a été
effectivement appelé parce que parce
qu'une hécatombe de blessure des
dernières assemblements mais à ce
moment-là la hiérarchie était assez
clair c'était Areola devant quand même
parce que plus de vécu plus d'expérience
parce qu'il a quand même l'occasion de
d'avoir du temps de jeu en Ligue Europa
par en Première League mais en Ligue
Europa qui partage un petit peu le temps
de jeu donc a priori ce sera plutôt lui
ce sera comme une surprise qui a le banc
à fond et au poste de gardiens on peut
quand même le mentionner que dans le cas
d'une absence de Mike mignon apparemment
c'est Steve mon mandat qui pourrait
plutôt être appelé aussi dans l'optique
d'avoir un cadre en fait d'avoir un
troisième gardien il passerait 3e
gardien et il serait plus dans
l'expérience dans le vécu du groupe un
groupe justement qui va peut-être
manquer un petit peu de vécu avec les
forfaits de Pogba et quantique oui parce
que troisième gardien déjà le deuxième
il joue pas forcément des gens il a fait
un petit cadeau en 2018 en le faisant
jouer un match mais sinon c'est quand
même assez compliqué oui généralement
c'est plus pour presque pour pour la vie
du groupe pour pour ce qui peut apporter
soit un gardien très expérimenté qui
peut apporter de par son vécu de par sa
place dans le groupe ou ça peut être un
jeune gardien qui est promis un grand
avenir qui vient découvrir ça peut être
ça aussi généralement c'est quand même
plus le gardien expérimenté et à ce
niveau là c'est tellement mandat
remplirait parfaitement cette fonction
alors on parle d'un petit jeune du
Bayern Munich matistel Mathis elle
est-ce que c'est pas un peu trop tôt
pour lui et que peut-être un peu plus
tard pour lui c'est un peu c'est un peu
trop tôt mais effectivement il fait un
super début de saison avec le Bayern et
c'est vrai que absolument personne l'a
mentionné alors aussi parce que même
dans les surprises bah il y a justement
des Martins terriers colomanie qui sont
encore un petit peu devant qui ont quand
même un petit peu plus de bouteilles qui
ont déjà un peu flirté aussi avec
l'équipe de France donc ces joueurs là
passeraient devant mais c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant de parler de matistel
parce que c'est peut-être vu son début
de carrière en tout cas au Bayern c'est
peut-être un joueur dont on va beaucoup
parler dans les années à venir en équipe
de France alors on nous demande c'est
quand ça arrive ça arrive Didier
Deschamps va arriver va annoncer la
liste et on vous la donnera cette liste
est-ce que Varane a été appelé Varane il
y a ce souci
on va dire ouais ce souci physique bah
là aussi c'est un joueur qui est un
début de saison quand même assez
compliqué à Manchester United qui a eu
un peu l'épée physique qui a pas du tout
enchaîné il a pas du tout enchaîner sauf
que Raphaël Varane bah un peu comme
Pogba comme Kanté comme Benzema c'est un
cadre indiscutable c'est un taulier
cette équipe de France un capitaine dans
l'âme donc s'il est apt physiquement
clairement idées des champs va le
prendre il va l'emmener maintenant c'est
aussi peut-être pour ça que Didier
Deschamps pourrait prendre un peu plus
de défenseur centraux on rappelle donc
ce sera pas le mystère de 23 mais de 26
donc ça fera un petit peu plus de
latitude de prendre encore plus de
remplaçant pour pallier à ses éventuels
doutes physique benferat discutable on
en a pas encore parlé de famille mais ça
y est il lui c'est imposé il y a plus
Pogba il y a plus compter est-ce que
c'est un peu la seule valeur sûre de de
ce milieu en tout cas c'est dans la
hiérarchie clairement le numéro 1 et ça
c'est incontestable à côté on peut
discuter entre Adria rabiot Yusuf Fofana
mais clairement il est voué à prendre
une dimension encore plus grande en
équipe de France
pense qu'il a déjà pris quand même assez
vite au Real Madrid il est assez vite
enfilé le costume qui est plutôt sa
taille jusqu'ici donc clairement on a on
aura besoin d'un grand choix médié en
équipe de France à la Coupe du monde
parce qu'il va être amené à jouer un
rôle de taulier il faut fana on en a
parlé il est il est arrivé quand même
extrêmement rapidement en équipe de
France et là on a l'impression que ça y
est c'est sûr qu'il reste bah on est un
peu oui cette impression parce que avec
Monaco il est extrêmement convaincant il
joue tous les matchs il ira très peu de
minutes il enchaîne sans arrêt il a pas
l'air forcément épuisé comme d'autres
comme d'autres joueurs peuvent l'être et
on peut même se demander si il sera pas
titulaire en fait parce qu'Adrien rabiot
il a toujours du mal à convaincre depuis
des années que ce soit une équipe de
France ou à la Juventus à la juvis il a
du mal à garder sa place de titulaire
donc c'est très compliqué pour lui on se
demande si finalement autre choix mini
Fofana c'est deux joueurs qui sont qui
sont connus aussi à l'AS Monaco donc
c'est c'est une paire qui pourrait qui
pourrait plutôt bien marcher qui
pourrait être intéressantes sur le
papier après on aura discutera selon le
schéma peut-être d'autres joueurs qui
pourront s'accorporer dans tout ça mais
Fofana clairement il a il arrive avec
presque déjà un statut effectivement et
on nous parle de Jules kunday aussi
Jules Kunde
défenseurs central qui joue au FC
Barcelone maintenant est-ce que je le
connais sa place et sur sa place elle
est plutôt plutôt sûre oui parce que là
aussi on est sur un joueur assez
expérimenté référencé au Barça
maintenant il y a l'avantage de pouvoir
jouer dans l'axe mais aussi sur le côté
droit de la défense donc il offre une
polyvalence un tout plus pour pour
Didier Deschamps oui sa présence elle
est assez sûr après est-ce qu'il sera à
la hauteur ça on ne sait pas est-ce
qu'il sera titulaire ça c'est encore
moins sûr on sait qu'il avait eu un euro
assez difficile contre la Suisse il
avait été vraiment difficulté quand la
France avait été éliminée il y a un an
donc forcément il faudrait se remettre
dans le bain d'une grande compétition
qui enfin réalise un peu son sous
potentiel mais il sera là normalement au
Qatar effectivement d'idées bien arrivé
sur le plateau de TF1 et qui va annoncer
cette liste dans quelques instants on
vous la diffusera dès qu'on aura bien
évidemment puisque nous ne pouvons pas
vous la vous aimez vous restez avec nous
on vous l'a dit on continue de prendre
vos commentaires
close catastrophique en équipe de France
alors je crois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas beaucoup les Marseillais et
qui n'en veut aucun en équipe de France
il aime pas trop galouser il aime pas
trop close alors que là ça a priori ça
risque d'être compliqué mais il gagne
12h à priori pour y aller un milieu
commun quand tu vas me ni alors quand tu
es non déjà ça c'est sûr et coman il y
en a pas vraiment au milieu de lui non
pas vraiment au milieu mais il sera là
normalement il sera là
ça va être aussi intéressant
effectivement il avait été pas mal on a
les noms Saliba euh d'ailleurs Tupa
mecano alors on a raté les gardiens
Raphaël Varane j'ai vu Ibrahima Konaté
milieu de terrain Eduardo camavinga
Youssouf ofana ça c'était assez sur
Matteo gain Douzi voilà game Douzi y est
Adrien rabiot et Aurélien trameli voilà
on vous le disait c'était assez sûr
Jordan verrez tout qui sera qui sera
Karim Benzema Kingsley coman on en
parlait
Ousmane Dembélé ah c'est sûr Olivier
Giroud bien évidemment Antoine Griezmann
puis Kylian Mbappe
et Christopher nku voilà c'est pour la
liste de l'équipe de France je viens la
dire loi mais vous ne vous inquiétez pas
vous l'aurez dans quelques instants en
live on va vous la montrer elle sera là
dans quelques instants ils seront 25
voilà c'est une liste c'est une liste à
25 qu'on aura donc pas 26 ça c'est aussi
c'est aussi un choix on a dit pour les
blessés mais il est pas allé jusqu'à 26
non plus c'est c'est quand même un choix
parce que on sait qu'il est des chambres
comme on l'a dit en début d'émission il
était plutôt partant sur une liste de 23
même si donc on le rappelle la FIFA
autorisé les équipes à avoir jusqu'à 26
joueurs à la Coupe du monde parce que on
le sait le calendrier très resserré et
on voit il y a beaucoup de blessés donc
c'est pour ça que la FIFA a voulu offrir
cette possibilité aux équipes de
renforcer un petit peu leur effectif de
voir un peu plus large pour gérer un peu
mieux les conditions physiques de chacun
Didier Deschamps il était plus partant
sur Instagram parce que qui dit plus de
joueurs dit plus d'égo à gérer dis plus
de joueurs qui ne vont pas avoir du
temps de jeu qui peuvent parfois mal le
vivre on le sait par exemple que Florent
Thauvin la Coupe du Monde 2018 il avait
quasiment pas jouer il veut jouer qu'une
minute et il avait pas si bien vécu et
ça peut être assez
frustrant pour pour ces joueurs là qui
forcément qui rêvent d'aller à une coupe
du monde pour la jouer pas pour rester
sur le banc donc finalement il reste sur
25 il s'arrête là ça peut se tenir selon
les joueurs qu'il prend finalement après
entre 23 25 on n'est pas son plus sur un
énorme Delta c'est pas non plus ce qui
va changer normalement toute la Coupe du
Monde de l'équipe de France voilà et
donc Mike Meignan n'est pas présente
dans cette liste de l'équipe de France
nous avons donc Hugo Lloris Alphonse
Areola et Steve Mandanda donc on le
disait tout à l'heure on prend ses
joueurs là Mike millions n'étant pas
remis à temps de sa blessure et ne fera
pas le voyage voilà il sera il sera pas
là parce que parce que pas apte
physiquement parce que il faut pouvoir
compter sur lui assez rapidement il y a
aussi des questions sur certains joueurs
comme Sadio Mané par exemple avec le
Sénégal ou est-ce que le joueur sera
disponible pour le 1er match ou est-ce
qu'il faudra attendre le troisième et du
coup est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie de le
prendre s'il sera disponible à partir du
troisième match ou des 8e de finale
ça crée pas mal d'incertitudes quand
même donc dans le cas de mcmenian a
priori Didier Deschamps à trancher dans
le vif si ma communion n'est pas
disponible dès le début assez rapidement
il vaut mieux prendre un autre gardien
et dans ce cas c'est tellement dordoga
qui va jouer ce rôle et ce sera surtout
normalement Lloris et Areola qui seront
un peu les deux premiers gardiens de
l'équipe de France donc nous avons la
liste qui est qui est ici que enfin la
liste vous voyez les voyez les joueurs
on n'a pas encore la liste avec les noms
en même temps comme ça vous pourrez vous
la vous la montrer en même temps mais
nous ne l'avons pas encore pour
l'instant elle arrivera bientôt Matteo
gain Douzi qui est youssoufana on disait
Kingsley coman Dembélé Lucas Hernandez
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il y a en
tout cas pour l'instant de d'énormes
surprises
Ibrahima Konaté a l'air d'être la plus
grande surprise un petit peu oui parce
que en défense il y avait beaucoup de
discussions donc clairement il y avait
Varane qui me PMB euh lucarlandaise
aussi qui devrait être amené à jouer
dans l'axe Jules koundé aussi peut jouer
dans l'axe on verra si j'aurai plus dans
l'axe ou plus à droite effectivement
après il y avait Ibrahima connecté on
pensait aussi
c'était les personnes que l'on a une
attitude de toute façon ils ont pas un
grand rôle dans cette équipe de France
non normalement ils auront pas un grand
rôle après ils peuvent aussi apporter
sur 20 25 minutes et faire basculer un
match je pense que le meilleur exemple
c'est un joueur qui ne partira pas je
pense titulaire en équipe de France
c'est édouardo camaïga mais il est là et
on l'a vu la saison dernière avec le
Real Madrid il était pas titulaire mais
c'est lui qui a renversé les matchs en
Ligue des Champions parce que sur 20 25
minutes il entre en jeu il peut apporter
quelque chose de différent et pas
apporter une fraîcheur que ma vinga pour
qu'au milieu il peut apporter de la
percussion balle aux pieds il peut
casser des lignes il peut vraiment
perturber tout le système du d'une
équipe donc c'est des joueurs qui
peuvent apporter là-dessus maintenant on
sait là il y a des blessés avant la
Coupe du monde ils risquent d'en avoir
aussi pendant la coupe du monde sur le
début sur les premiers matchs on va
faire très attention à ça voir ce
weekend ce weekend
et c'est intéressant d'en parler parce
que la liste jusqu'ici elle n'est pas
officielle c'est-à-dire que Didier
Deschamps va rendre sa liste
officiellement à la FIFA je crois ce
lundi prochain ou peut-être celui
d'après avant le premier match des Bleus
mais d'ici là il aura encore le droit de
faire des changements surtout dans
l'optique d'une blessure s'il y a un
joueur qui se blesse il pourra encore
changer et appeler un remplaçant par
contre une fois que la Coupe du monde
aura commencé une fois que la France
aura joué son premier match là il pourra
plus appeler de remplaçant si un BC bah
tant pis et le groupe sera réduit d'où
le principe de prendre unités en même
temps on disait lisser l'argile veut
dire que si un joueur ne joue pas il
peut faire la gueule et il faut aussi
des joueurs capables d'encaisser
d'accepter le fait de ne pas jouer en
fait il faut des joueurs comme je sais
pas Christopher un coucou par exemple
qui n'est pas prévu pour être titulaire
peut-être lui il a un rôle central dans
son club alexish en Allemagne est-ce
qu'il accepterait il faut qu'il accepte
ce rôle ouais il faut absolument qu'il
qu'il accepte alors il y a des joueurs
qui l'acceptent il y a des gens qui
acceptent moins bien et après c'est
c'est un peu un jeu d'équilibré c'est
finalement parce que il y a peut-être
des joueurs qui sont plus talentueux qui
sont des simplement meilleurs à leurs
postes mais qui vont l'accepter un petit
peu moins bien donc il y a des chambres
doivent choisir un peu ce qu'il
privilégie peut-être qu'il va faire qui
va changer le privilège le poste selon
le joueur qui va chercher finalement la
bonne formule la bonne alchimie
après ça il prend il a pris la
température sur les dernières assembles
à mon équipe de France on sait qu'il
prend tout le temps la température
pendant les saisons d'appeler d'appeler
les joueurs d'appeler leur entourage
contacter les clubs de savoir un petit
peu comment ça se passe avec tel joueur
de se rendre compte un petit peu de son
état d'esprit et de ce qui peut apporter
à cette équipe de France donc tout ça
c'est un équilibre que jusqu'ici qui
descend a quand même pas trop mal pas
trop mal négocié alors Jordan versetou
est-ce que Jordan vero tout et c'est pas
c'est pas lui finalement la grande
surprise cinq sélections pour le joueur
qui joue à l'Olympique de Marseille
c'est c'est est-ce que c'est pas lui
finalement la grande surprise si
l'appareil quand même comme une grande
surprise je pense qu'au milieu de
terrain on a parlé notamment de kamaviga
gain Douzi j'allais dire verratti
l'opératine de France
a priori donc je verrai tout aussi il y
avait peut-être que deux places pour
trois finalement les trois Yvon ce qui
veut dire aussi si je ne m'abuse qu'on a
donc 6 milieux de terrain de métier
exactement donc ça aussi c'est
intéressant
ça pose la question justement c'est ce
que je me demandais est-ce que ça veut
pas dire que l'équipe de France pourrait
potentiellement jouer dans un 4 3
c'est pas forcément le système qu'on
imaginait naturellement c'est pas ce à
quoi on a été habitué depuis maintenant
4 ou 5 ans on change une liste aussi
proche de d'une grande échéance c'est
pas forcément une bonne idée ça aussi ça
peut paraître un petit peu un petit peu
étonnant après on voyait que l'équipe de
France est dans ça allait pas ça
marchait pas bien il fallait changer des
choses dit l'échange je pense qu'il
était un peu obligé quoi qu'il arrive de
prendre des risques donc on verra ce qui
nous ce qui nous réserve et de façon
après il va pas s'en conférence de
presse donc il va certainement
s'expliquer un petit peu sur ses choix
là et sur ce qu'il attend mais oui pour
revenir à Jordan verre et tout oui c'est
quand même une surprise il y a six mois
avant qu'il signale l'OM on en parle
assez on en parlait assez peu en équipe
de France il y a eu les forfaits de
Pogba de Kanté
donc sur le papier je me pose un petit
peu des questions sur la place de Jordan
verettou et notamment en fait pas tant
sur vert et tout mais aussi sur les
profils qu'on a en équipe de France avec
des joueurs peut-être qu'ils vont se
ressembler un petit peu je pense à un
joueur alors il partait de très loin on
a pas beaucoup parlé mais tant qu'ils
n'ont délais qui cartonne cette saison
avec Naples qui est totalement en pleine
renaissance qui a porté peut-être un
profil différent un profil plus porteur
de balle la pouvoir casser des lignes à
pouvoir peser aussi dans la surface et
être un peu plus avoir plus de punch il
y a pas forcément ce profil actuellement
je pense tu as mis l'équipe de France à
part peut-être un peu de camavinga et
encore on est sur des milieux on va dire
frein à main on peut appeler ça comme ça
on est sur des milieux prudents on va
dire ouais peut-être on est moins sur
des sur des joueurs clairement à
vocation enfin si on n'a pas un milieu
qui pourrait avoir cet aspect un petit
peu de milieu offensif après encore une
fois ça va dépendre aussi du système de
l'équipe de France on pense à par
exemple à ce qui pourrait être un cadre
de 3 comme comme la France avait la
Coupe du Monde 2018 et c'est ce qu'il a
mené au sacre on avait en avant centre
Olivier Giroud là ça serait par exemple
Karim Benzema avec Antoine Griezmann
numéro 10 Antoine Griezmann qui se
régalait dans ce système dans un coin
dans un cadre 33 comme le suppute du
coup maintenant vu qu'il y a 6 millions
de terrain est-ce qu'on peut faire
reculer Antoine Griezmann un peu plus
bas sur le terrain c'est quelque chose
qu'on a déjà vu avec la Chico de Madrid
ou Griezmann reculé vraiment symbole
même de ça il avait porté le numéro 8 le
dico de Madrid et il avait l'air prêt à
se conforter dans ce rôle et c'est
peut-être un rôle qui tiendra juste sur
la fin de sa carrière c'est aussi une
évolution qui pourrait avoir de par son
profil et ce qui pourrait aujourd'hui
reculer à ce point-là ça paraît quand
même un petit peu étonnant il y a aussi
des connexions des automatismes qui ont
été créés un petit peu avec Mbappé avec
Benzema ça serait quand même une énorme
surprise là pour le coup s'il y ait des
champs reculer là-dessus alors je vois
des commentaires je vois quelqu'un qui
poste des commentaires en boucle alors
on va lui répondre les défenseurs Lucas
Hernandez alors clos lui il va pas du
coup varan goundé on est sur une bonne
défense effectivement c'est pas le
secteur qui nous en qui nous inquiète le
plus on va dire
réservoir peut-être
j'allais dire c'est peut-être là où la
France a le meilleur réservoir mais d'un
côté on attaque aussi c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire mais oui en termes
de défense de défenseur centraux
l'équipe de France a un excellent
réservoir et se permettre de ne pas
emmener William Saliba ou Benoît
badiashi ou d'ailleurs ou pas mécano je
ne sais pas si il est dans la liste du
coup je suis pas sûr d'être mécano n'y
est pas mais si si pardon excusez-moi
donc c'est surtout William Saliba
finalement qui n'est pas là
je reprends je reprends je reprends la
salibayi défenseur Hernandez Hernandez
qui peut MB Konaté kunday Pavard Saliba
ou pas mécano Varane
ça fait quand même beaucoup de
défenseurs
donc finalement on a Saliba donc on a on
a quitté
Varane Saliba ou pas mécano en centrale
en Lucas Hernandez et Konaté et coup de
mai en fait c'est sur les c'est c'est
Lucas Digne qu'il n'y ait pas par contre
en fait c'est Lucas Digne qui n'y est
pas donc c'est plutôt plutôt à gauche
finalement qu'on a ni faire le Mendy ni
Lucas Digne oui ni l'un ni l'autre ça
paraît quand même 6 ça signifie que Théo
hollandaise évidemment va être le
titulaire à gauche c'est peut-être
plutôt son frère en fait Lucas qui
risque de de le remplacer à partir de là
je pense qu'on qu'on se profile vers ça
et Pavard étant à droite vu le kunday
peut dépanner même si ce n'est pas
forcément son poste mais c'est un peu ce
qui pourrait se passer peut-être que là
Didier Deschamps a fait le choix de la
polyvalence des joueurs il a pris
défenseurs centraux capables de jouer
sur un côté c'est un petit peu ça là qui
s'est dessiné effectivement parce qu'en
fait on a appart et wernandez on n'a pas
de latérale de latérale de métier dans
cette équipe de France même Benjamin
Pavard qui est quand même beaucoup amené
à jouer défenseur central qui est
toujours été qui a toujours revendiqué
être plus avant tout défenseur central
que latéral droit même s'il a très
clairement éclos à ce poste là en équipe
de France donc effectivement là c'est
clairement le choix de la polyvalence et
finalement bah on est défenseurs
centraux il y avait beaucoup de
questions beaucoup de choix on va dire
les gens a pris un peu un peu un peu
tout le monde donc finalement il y a
personne de laisser pour compte par
contre effectivement sur les latéraux
donc il y aura pas de Jonathan close
donc clairement on se dirige je pense
vers un système à 4 défenseurs et sur le
côté gauche aussi le choix est clair ça
va être vraiment les les frères
irlandaises qui auront la la
responsabilité du jeu effectivement
alors je vous redonne la liste exacte
les gardiens Areola Lloris Mandanda mais
n'y en n'est pas là Alban non plus Alban
Lafont non plus les défenseurs Lucas
Hernandez Théo Hernandez son frère qui
PMB Konaté Kunde Pavard Saliba ou pas
mécano Varad pas de Digne pas de ferment
Mendi les milieux cannabis Kama vinga
Youssoupha rabiot traumani verre et tout
et les attaquants Benzema command
Dembélé Giroud Griezmann Mbappé et nku
voici pour la liste et Didier Deschamps
devraient pas tarder à arriver
maintenant en conférence de presse il
est attendu juste après son interview au
20H qui vient de se terminer vous voulez
aller j'imagine attendez là vous avez
les joueurs qui participeront je vais
vous passer la liste juste à côté comme
ça puisque vous pouvez retrouver sur le
site du Figaro hop on va la mettre comme
ça et la zoomer un peu pour vous les 25
bleus
c'est intéressant parce qu'on a dit que
qu'il y aura pas a priori de défense à 5
alors c'est pas impossible non plus
parce qu'on sait que notamment sur sur
le côté droit commun exactement a déjà
joué à ce rôle là alors on était
convaincu pas convaincu en tout cas
c'est une option qui a déjà employé des
gens et te renanaise pourra tout à fait
occuper un rôle de piston gauche ça il y
a pas vraiment de problème maintenant
c'est pas une liste faite pour jouer à 5
c'est pas une liste conçue dans cette
on sait que c'est là où ça pêche oui
c'est clairement là où ça pêche parce
que c'est là où il y a moins de vécu
moins d'expérience moins de joueurs
aussi de très grands niveaux clairement
on va pas on va pas se le cacher après
c'est sûr que Pogba compter cette saison
c'était franchement pas ça c'était très
compliqué si cette saison Pogba il a pas
joué cette saison en même temps donc la
saison dernière non plus la saison
dernière aussi ça a été très compliqué
donc c'est même la question qu'on se
pose un peu est-ce que c'est pas un mal
pour un bien que au moins Pogba a été
très clairement et physiquement écarté
de l'équipe de France il y a pas eu
cette incertitude de on le prend on sait
pas si il sera là on n'est pas sûr au
moins ça a été assez clair oui
malheureusement c'est aujourd'hui un
secteur de jeu où l'équipe de France
arrive avec beaucoup moins d'assurance
par rapport aux autres favoris de la
Coupe du Monde
Scott qui me dit c'était mieux la fois à
la place derrière voilà oui on en parle
tout à l'heure alors qu'est-ce qui
justifie ce choix d'aréola c'est juste
parce qu'il a plus de vécu et que c'est
lui qui est un peu programmé pour être
numéro 3 et aussi il va il va se tenir
un peu tranquille derrière derrière lui
c'est peut-être plus de vécu plus
d'expérience on est sur Champion du
Monde 2018 du coup on a le risque
montant d'arrêtola comme en 2018
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être aussi un
moyen pour d'idées des chances de se
rassurer un petit peu on a dit encore
une fois il y a pas Pogba il y a pas
compté il y a un petit manque de vécu
peut-être dans cette équipe et des
joueurs parfois qui ont été vécu mais
qui n'ont qui n'ont pas les conditions
physiques pour être vraiment dans les
meilleures conditions comme Varane qui
me PND voir éventuellement Benzema donc
c'est peut-être bien aussi d'avoir ces
joueurs qui vont solidifier le groupe
qui vont rassurer un petit peu tout le
monde
maintenant sur les performances je
trouve qu'un caleban à fond était assez
impressionnant ces derniers temps avec
avec Nantes ça fait plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années il lui arrive d'avoir
des trous d'air mais aujourd'hui c'est
un gardien plus que solide en lien c'est
presque étonnant de le voir encore jouer
au FC Nantes certes européen mais qui
joue un peu le maintien en Ligue 1 parce
que c'est clairement aujourd'hui Alban à
fond ce n'est clairement pas un gardien
qui joue le maintien en Ligue 1 par
exemple qui joue que entre guillemets à
Monaco ouais tout à fait alors encore
une fois c'est comme Fofana on l'a dit
tout à l'heure c'était une assez
fulgurante et finalement ils se
retrouvent à être en fait titulaire en
équipe de France a priori il parle il
est particulière avec avec Aurélien
tremini là c'est un peu c'est un peu
être mis rapidement sur le devant de la
scène en raison des lacunes et des
soucis au milieu de terrain dont on a
parlé et des gens qui s'est montré
confiance pour qu'ils peuvent Varane et
Benzema qui seront qui sont appelés on
pourra peut-être kunday aussi blessé et
il faut voir comment ils se remette
jusqu'au 22 voilà on a 13 jours pour les
remettre sur pied on va dire voilà 13
jours et puis évidemment s'il y ait des
champs a décidé de les appeler
clairement c'est qu'il a eu des
informations positives en tout cas qu'il
est rassuré qu'il est assez sûr de son
choix et maintenant c'est aussi
l'avantage de cette liste de 25 c'est
que dans le cas où un joueur est
finalement un petit peu court qu'il a un
peu limite sur le premier match c'est
pas sûr qu'il puisse vraiment tenir sa
place normalement il y a il y a des
options il y a ce qui nous dit il a mis
virer tout à la place de fekira Nabil
Fekir pas vraiment pressenti pour être à
la Coupe du Monde bah pas vraiment
pressenti alors je suis pas sûr alors
c'est pas le même poste mais c'est
effectivement un joueur qui aurait pu
prendre la place d'un milieu de terrain
après on verra ce que Didier Deschamps à
en tête pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pris
6000 autres terrains on a hâte que
quelqu'un lui pose la question en
conférence de presse bien sûr mais
effectivement Nabil Fekir on a même pas
mentionné son jusqu'ici et à tort je
pense parce que avec le bêtise alors il
y a eu quelques peu quelques peu
quelques pépins physiques mais il a été
énorme la saison dernière il a été
prépondérant dans une grosse saison du
bêtises en Liga et surtout en Coupe du
Roi où ils ont remporté la Coupe du Roi
c'est un joueur un taulier aujourd'hui à
aux bêtises qui fait une très belle
saison Ligue 1 qui a survolé son groupe
en Ligue Europa c'est un joueur qui
méritait d'être mentionné et ce qui
méritait sa place dans cette équipe de
France pour jouer la Coupe du monde
peut-être pas parce que encore une fois
la concurrence en attaque elle est elle
est monstrueuse elle est Martin Terrier
en acoly on en a parlé ils sont dans une
forme incroyable et il y a juste pas de
place pour eux c'est juste pas possible
donc Nabil feker il peut pas y être mais
effectivement il méritait d'être
mentionné d'être un peu dans dans la
discussion calme au niveau on a oublié
de parler de on en a parlé d'être dans
Bel-Air on en a parlé on l'a on a dit
que vu ce qui faisait à Naples il aurait
pu être dans cette liste et que ça
aurait été un ajout pas comme comme
feker finalement un profil un peu plus
créatif ouais tout à fait un profil plus
créatif plus casseurs de lignes plus
percutant
d'embeller alors c'est pas un joueur qui
enchaîne les 90 minutes un Naples et
souvent ils sont en cours de jeu où il
entre en cours de jeu mais il y aura
quasiment pas un match il arrive quand
même plutôt bien enchaîné et surtout il
est très impactant et effectivement au
milieu de terrain il a un profil un
petit peu différent c'est vrai que on
verra comment Didier Deschamps on va
justifier son choix au milieu de terrain
mais c'est vrai que sur sur le papier on
se dit que s'il fallait prendre 6
millions de terrain il y avait peut-être
moyen de faire la place pour un don
Bellay qui a un joueur un petit peu
différent des autres maintenant il y a
pas c'est pas non plus une grosse
surprise il avait pas été appelé depuis
un an et demi en équipe de France
ça Renaissance elle est quand même très
récente ça aurait été assez
extraordinaire pour lui de faire la
Coupe du Monde on nous parle aussi de
faire la Mendy on a pas trop parlé aussi
qui est pas capable de jouer piston lui
c'est ces dernières prestations en bleu
qui qui ont joué ouais surtout ça sa
dernière en septembre contre le Danemark
ou là vraiment il est complètement passé
au travers alors c'est pas le seul mais
là pour le coup il fait un peu les frais
de ça
ouais c'est quand même un petit peu un
petit peu surprenant que Didier
Deschamps finalement privilégie vraiment
le côté polyvalence défenseur centraux
qui va pas chercher ce latéral gauche de
métier dans le cas où dans cette
doublure à Théo Hernandez après
jusqu'ici tu es en andazy il a quand
même été assez fiable en équipe de
France il y a pas de souci si tout va
bien il va enchaîner les 90 minutes sur
90 minutes avec les Bleus à la Coupe du
Monde maintenant oui faire la Mendy on
se demandait en fait qui allait être
préféré entre faire le midi et Lucas
Digne bah finalement c'est aucun des
deux aucun des deux et
Didier les gens fait le choix de la
polyvalence il prend défenseur centraux
capables de jouer sur un côté un autre
défenseur dont on a pas parlé c'est pire
qu'à loulou pire qu'à loulou qui n'est
pas le plus connu des défenseurs même si
il commence à bien jouer quand même
comme champion en Italie en dernier avec
Milan et en disant titulaire ouais en
passant titulaire et en s'approprie en
totalement c'est le place de titulaire à
l'AC Milan la Russie c'est un joueur
vraiment prometteur et tout à l'heure on
parlait de machistel dont on parlera
peut-être dans les années à venir en
équipe de France je pense que Pierre
kalulu on peut rapidement en parler
surtout qu'on est sur un poste latéral
droit ou les choix ne sont pas ne sont
pas pléthore pour le coup Benjamin
Pavard on le sait c'est quand même très
ambivalent c'est c'est assez difficile
pour lui s'impose un équipe de France et
même au Bayern Munich où il est assez
discuté c'est pas l'intérêt à le droit
de métier sinon a priori l'autre option
aujourd'hui c'est Jules kundai
l'appareil par latérale droit de métier
donc effectivement pire qu'à loulou il
aurait pas fait tâche mais là clairement
dans la logique de Deschamps ça aurait
été enfin s'il avait remplacé juste un
des défenseurs ça aurait été quand même
assez difficile à comprendre les mirages
qui nous parlent de si Macan il est ce
qu'il aurait mérité d'y être si Makan un
peu jeune encore un peu tendre peut-être
ouais je pense qu'il passait quand même
un petit peu derrière dans cette
hiérarchie aussi où il y a ou pas mécano
Saliba Konaté déjà sur les trois on
était pas sûr qu'ils aient tous pour
couper des défenseurs pourtant bien
réputé et déjà rompu un petit peu au
milieu de l'équipe de France si
maintenant il arrive derrière
malheureusement lui souffre quand même
pas mal de la concurrence du fait que
l'équipe de France la France est très
riche à son poste effectivement on a
l'un des meilleurs réservoirs à l'avant
et à l'arrière on a dit depuis tout à
l'heure mais les milieux c'est un peu là
où ça pêche et vous nous le dites
beaucoup dans les commentaires mot qui
est dans des boucle le Parisien il
aurait pu en être aussi on cherche les
défenseurs polyvalents ouais il était
aussi dans la discussion là clairement
on est sur un défenseur très polyvalent
après au PSG il a eu un temps de jeu
assez réduit
il a été en équipe de France lorsqu'il
était encore à Leipzig il avait déjà été
appelé
son vécu il est quand même un petit plus
limité dans la forme dans dans ce qu'il
a montré cette saison tout ce qu'il a eu
au moins l'occasion de montrer sur son
temps de jeu là aussi l'arrivée quand
même un petit peu un petit peu derrière
tout le monde
BKD qui nous dit pourquoi pas Alan
Saint-Maximin pourquoi il n'y est pas là
à Saint-Maximin alors c'est des bons
joueurs tout ça mais est-ce que c'est le
niveau équipe de France surtout quand on
voit l'attaque Benzema coman Dembélé
Giroud Griezmann Mbappé ngku pas
Griezmann qui peut traverser une période
un peu compliquée en Ligue 1 mais on
sait comment il est en équipe de France
il y a pas la place en fait non il y a
absolument pas la place c'est ça fait
déjà enfin voilà on a tout à l'heure on
a dit on avait pas du tout parlé du
Fekir pourtant dans pas mal de sélection
je pense que c'est un un choix qui
pourrait assez naturellement s'imposer
même dans de belles sélections
clairement je pense qu'elle a un maximum
il revient encore derrière c'est un très
bon joueur c'est un joueur très
intéressant et un profil assez unique
mais là clairement je pense qu'il a
juste pas la place en équipe de France
pour être la surprise au Qatar
effectivement alors on avait préparé en
plus c'est une petite une petite liste
je vais vous montrer la petite liste on
avait fait les absents les absents et
ben le problème de ces absents c'est que
il y a plus qu'un milieu qui a pas été
pris finalement de ces Boubacar Camara
qui était dans la discussion et qui a
pas été pris est-ce qu'il y a un
deuxième milieu qu'on aurait pu penser
qui pourrait être pris et qui n'a pas
on en parlait voilà tu as envie non mais
là on en parlerai pas tant que ça on
n'osait pas trop forcément en parler
aussi parce que parce qu'il venait de
très très loin il arrivait à Naples cet
été en sortant les pailles Renaissance
pareil on se sentait jamais il y a 6
mois murmurait son nom en équipe de
France ça paraissait complètement ça
paraissait enfin ubuesque
maintenant sur ce qu'il a montré à
Naples Naples qui est roule absolument
sur le rock qui est encore à vaincu qui
a été extraordinaire en Ligue des
champions qui est très séduisant c'est
un élément clé aujourd'hui de cette
équipe du Napoli ça s'arrête pas du tout
été incohérent sur le papier de le voir
en équipe de France et ce code qui nous
parle encore de terrier dommage qu'il
n'aurait pas eu sa chance je pense au
moins pour les matchs de poules oui mais
derrière c'est un très bon joueur à
Rennes mais est-ce que c'est un bon
joueur en international sur le problème
bah le problème c'est que on a pas
encore la réponse il aurait fallu avoir
un début de réponse avant là c'est un
peu c'est un peu trop tard maintenant
on verra pour les pour les années à
venir en tout cas si Martin Terrier
continue sur sa lancée arène clairement
à la fin à la fin de la fin de la saison
et quand il y aura une nouvelle trêve et
quand il y aura de nouveaux rendez-vous
internationaux son nom va peut-être se
faire murmurer un petit peu plus fort
mais c'est vrai que sur le papier il
avait il avait ce côté peut-être un peu
23e joueur dernier joueur de la liste
petite Joker on attaque en plus on a
parlé de polyvalence en défense pour le
coup Martin Terrier il a un profil
relativement polyvalent en attaque il
aurait pu apporter des choses assez
différentes effectivement avec cet
attaquant des champs a fait son choix de
rester comme ça alors voyez vous vous le
voyez ici c'est la salle de conférence
de presse dans laquelle va arriver d'ici
quelques temps il y a des champs on vous
tiendra au courant dès qu'il sera là on
va vous remettre la liste puisque c'est
ça qui vous intéresse on le sait et on
continue de parler à des de joueurs mais
il ouvre alors vous l'expliquer faire
leur manière d'en parler ouais c'était
Fofana on n'a pas parlé de l'Ouest les
Fofana ouest qui était alors pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas trop parce que
ils jouent de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique
il a sorti il avait sorti une très
grosse saison à Leicester il s'était
blessé et maintenant il est à Chelsea
c'est encore blessé il pouvait revenir
mais là aussi c'est un peu trop court
pour lui oui c'était trop court et
sur des joueurs comme Varennes Quimper
on peut être un petit peu plus clément
se dire que bon ok si il sera prêt un
peu à la limite limite ça passe quand
même du moment qu'il est prêt au bon
moment maintenant sur des joueurs moins
expérimentés moins affirmés ça c'est
plus difficile à avaler pour pour Didier
les champs maintenant sur sur le poste
encore une fois on en a parlé la
concurrence elle est absolument
monstrueuse sur le poste de défenseur
central il est tellement fourni en
équipe de France pour websley Fofana
c'était trop court l'échantillon à
Chelsea finalement était assez léger il
a dû digérer son transfert il était
blessé finalement c'était c'était trop
juste pour lui mais là aussi c'est un
nom dont on reparlera peut-être dans les
dans les prochains mois effectivement et
on ose reparle encore une fois d'Alban
Lafont Alban Lafon qui aurait pu aussi
être là à la place
Carolina qui nous parle de Kanté quand
est blessé il ne pouvait pas être là je
crois qu'on a encore parlé de Pogba non
non c'était Mathis qui nous dit pourquoi
mais n'y en est pas là mais il n'y a
aussi est blessé il ne pourra pas être
présent pour cette liste encore une fois
pas de joueurs du Stade Rennais ni
bourijo juste les gardiens oui mais
c'est déjà pas mal un joueur du Stade
Rennais à la Coupe du Monde c'est pas si
fréquent on va peut-être pas retourner
dans les stats c'est c'est pas si
fréquent alors bonjour bon je pense que
le lit vraiment il est toujours enfin
après si on considère comme un joueur
plus minothérain mais c'est un joueur un
peu entre le milieu et l'attaque en tout
cas dans dans cette équipe de France et
dans les profils qui sont proposés je
pense qu'il était quand même encore très
loin en termes de vécu et même s'il fait
une magnifique saison à Rennes ça y a
absolument rien à dire c'est un des
taulia à Rennes qui fait encore une
belle saison en lien mais là aussi
c'était encore bien juste quand même
alors l'idée je suis on devrait arriver
d'ici 5 minutes pour cela
alors on veut nous faire parler d'abord
de Fekir avant en fait qui recolo Mani
Scott qui nous dit colomanie que le
Boigny il joue Francfort il joue la
Ligue des Champions il a [ __ ]
d'ailleurs en Ligue des Champions mais
voilà le secteur offensif on l'a dit
Benzema coman Dembélé
il faut être un cadavre ouais alors il
faut qu'il y a une blessure de Dembélé
par exemple voilà il faut une blessure
au dernier moment parce que là en fait
c'est c'est trop fourni il y a pas
d'absents il y a pas de de joueurs qu'on
peut qu'on peut vraiment retirer
Benzema Mbappé Griezmann c'est un
discutable Shiro on en a parlé en début
d'émission il a clairement gagné sa
place il l'a mérité il va il peut jouer
un rôle essentiel à cette équipe de
France clairement colomanie dans le
profil d'un géo peut-être pas dans le
même profil mais en tout cas plus sur le
même poste sur ce poste d'avant centre
clairement il passe derrière et derrière
aussi il faut aussi des joueurs des
joueurs un petit peu de côté comme coman
Dembélé à priori c'est ce sur quoi va
s'appuyer Didier Deschamps sur des
joueurs un peu de déséquilibre qui sont
alors coman un peu moins en forme avec
le Bayern c'était plus compliqué mais
Ousmane Dembélé qui part même avec un
statut potentiellement titulaire si
l'équipe de France est dans dans un
cadre de 3 4 3 sur le côté droit ce sera
pour Dembélé RZ nous demande est-ce que
Griezmann sera indiscutable dans cette
équipe
bah question sensible une question qui
qui peut pourtant se poser parce que on
va voir dans quel système vous pouvez
évoluer cette équipe de France on s'est
posé la question de voir 6000 autres
terrains on était un petit peu un petit
peu surpris je vais vous montrer la
avant ce live pour tout vous dire on
s'est dit comment peut jouer l'équipe de
France et on s'est dit voilà comment
pouvez jouer l'équipe de France
en jouant à 4 donc on aurait le risque
dans les cages Hernandez et Varane en
défense centrale théorlandaise n'est pas
avoir sur le côté choix mini rabiot au
milieu et Mbappe Griezmann Dembélé
Benzema en attaque sauf que ce plan avec
autant de défense avec autant de milieux
est-ce qu'on apprécie 6 milieux pour en
faire jouer que deux là ça paraît
étonnant d'avoir 4 milieux remplaçant
après évidemment
il peut y avoir comme peut y avoir des
blessés très vite on sera content si
jamais on a on a un banc assez staffé
maintenant je pense pas que ce soit
vraiment la logique de Didier Deschamps
d'anticiper des blessures en tout cas
pas sur ces postes là en plus c'est pas
forcément un secteur en danger
physiquement
donc oui ça me paraît quand même un
petit peu un petit peu étonnant s'il dit
des gens veut jouer comme ça ça paraît
plus logique du coup de gens 4 3 de par
la liste qu'il a fait et là
effectivement pour revenir à Griezmann
ça pose la question est-ce que Griezmann
aurait sa place dans un code 3 est-ce
que ça serait Benzema dans l'axe et
Mbappé Griezmann sur les côtés est-ce
que c'est vraiment la meilleure
utilisation qu'on peut avoir de de trio
la question se pose et
Ousmane Dembélé pour le coup serait
beaucoup plus
intitulée naturel dans un système comme
celui-là effectivement est-ce qu'il y a
Mbappe oui bien sûr qu'il M a P on
n'allait pas il avait pas faire une
liste sans Mbappé c'est quasiment la
même qu'en 2018 sans pogbaï Kanté on
sait que des champs il aime quelque
chose quand même c'est la continuité
il aime bien continuité après il va pas
en avoir beaucoup effectivement au
milieu même en défense c'est assez
fragile on se pose un peu des questions
dans l'ensemble c'est quand même
l'équipe plus ou moins l'ossature de
l'équipe de France champion du monde
après on verra comment ça joue si c'est
un cadre de 3 ce sera vraiment ce qu'on
a vu l'équipe de France en 2018 en tout
cas le même système pas avec les mêmes
hommes bien sûr parce que Karim Benzema
et Olivier girous sont deux attaquants
très différents
maintenant sur la question du système
voilà nous n'imaginait plus un cadre de
3 naturellement pour exploiter au mieux
les qualités notamment de Antoine
Griezmann qui est centrale à cette
équipe de France on verra sur sur quoi
Didier Deschamps veut partir et ce qui
ambitionne en tout cas avec cette liste
Abdel admin qui lui demande c'est quelle
chaîne qui diffuse la conférence de
presse et bah vous pouvez rester ici la
conférence de presse sera diffusée ici
dès que Didier Deschamps arrivera mais
il n'est pas encore ici vous inquiétez
pas on va vous le diffuser dès qu'il
arrive vous pourrez le suivre the
réplique avec Kingsley coman pourrait
jouer défenseur droit dans un système
oui on l'a dit mais dans un système à 4
est-ce que il pourrait être aussi bas
sur un terrain clairement non je pense
pas que ça soit l'option de Didier
Deschamps effectivement dans un trois
dans un trois sacs 2 il a déjà joué
piston droit il peut plus ou moins tenir
sur ce rôle et c'est pas impossible
qu'il le fasse par séquence on l'a dit
peut-être que des gens va vouloir
employer système sur une courte période
dans un match en fin de match par
exemple ou avoir comment il peut jouer
ce rôle là mais dans une défense A4
clairement il le fera pas normalement
qui se les coman il part avec un statut
de remplaçant dans cette équipe de
France alors on nous parlait tout à
l'heure de d'Antoine Griezmann et de son
statut contesté Hitachi qui me dit mais
d'un côté quand on vous dit Coupe du
Monde l'équipe de France il pense
directement à Antoine Griezmann et oui
c'est sûr Scott qui nous parle de de
Diaby nku ça aurait été pas mal alors
une couille Diaby joue aussi en
Allemagne au Bayern Leverkusen Diaby ça
aurait été pas mal en Joker aussi en
plus oui oui c'était un petit peu dans
dans cette option des Martin intérieur
Honda colomanie Moussa Diaby il était un
petit peu dans ce range là voir Wissem
Ben Yedder dans une si on va un petit
peu plus loin on n'avait pas encore pour
nous saison d'ailleurs je pense oui
quand même au moins qu'on prononce son
nom je pense même si clairement il
partait pour ne pas être dans la liste
mais oui pour en revenir à Moussa Diaby
c'est un joueur qui rodait un petit peu
derrière mais il a encore une fois il
faut faire des choix en attaque ça sert
à rien de prendre 10 attaquants parce
que sinon il y en a clairement qui vont
venir pour rien
voilà c'était difficile à ce moment-là
de lui faire une place ou encore encore
une fois en enlevant peut-être un milieu
de terrain mais on a envie du coup de
savoir pourquoi Didier Deschamps il va
nous expliquer en conférence de presse
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pris ses 6000 de
terrain pour que ce qu'il en apprécient
alors Caro qui lui dit il manque un
remplaçant pour le poste de latéral
gauche le frère le frère Hernandez faut
remplacer l'autre frère en fait bah
c'est en tout cas dans l'optique de
Didier Deschamps c'est clairement ça là
pour l'instant on va le voir il va
sûrement parler aussi un petit peu sur
des choix en défense l'absence de de
latéraux de métier en fait il y a pas un
seul vrai latéral de pure latéral droit
de pur latéral gauche sont que des
joueurs dont il s'agit de polyvalence
donc ce sera intéressant à voir mais oui
c'est un choix en tout cas très clair de
on prend avant tout quatre défenseurs
centraux parce que parce qu'il faut
renforcer ça enfin que de besanteur sont
trop de métiers plus ceux qui peuvent
jouer éventuellement à ce poste là c'est
à dire quasiment tous en fait alors
s3npa qui tout à l'heure a critiqué
Benjamin morigo en mettant des petites
couleurs
vertes et jaunes il nous dit et Nicolas
Palois pourquoi il serait pas Nicolas
Fallois
[Musique]
même si nous dit top 5 des meilleurs
défenseurs de Ligue 1
qui est un très bon joueur de foot mais
on parle de Coupe du Monde Morgan je
pense qu'au mieux je verrai bien un duo
Fofana on pourrait avoir le duo de l'AS
Monaco qui a fait du beau boulot à l'AS
Monaco vous voyez si oui c'est c'est ce
qui peut tout à fait se dessiner on va
voir ce que va privilégier Deschamps
parce que Adrien rabiot on l'a dit tout
à l'heure
on reste quand même très souvent sur
notre fin que ce soit en équipe de
France ou à la Juventus on a un peu du
mal à vraiment lui trouver de l'énergie
du mordant dans ses prestations à lui
trouver vraiment son rôle sa place ce
qu'il arrive vraiment sa capacité à
faire la différence pourtant il en a
parfois été un petit peu capable avec
avec le PSG
donc peut-être que Youssouf Fofana
finalement ça marchera mieux avec
Aurélien de chamini après la question
encore une fois ça va être celle du
système et à ce niveau là alors autant
pour la défense on a réglé le cas ça
serait une c'est clair autant sur le
milieu d'attaque il y a beaucoup de
questions et selon si c'est un milieu à
deux ou un milieu à trois ça ça change
absolument tout effectivement alors on
nous demande pourquoi on n'a pas pris
Chancel MBA parce qu'il est peut-être
international dans notre pays et que on
peut pas sélectionner des joueurs comme
ça vous satisfoko le le le soldat de
Ligue des Champions qui joue à Nantes
maintenant pareil et on nous parle de
tôle ISO quand un tolisso qui était
revenu à Lyon pour se relancer on peut
parler aussi de Lacazette
c'est raté oui c'est trop court pourtant
Lacazette c'est un super début de saison
à Lyon mais là aussi il partait de
franchement d'extrêmement loin
clairement dans cette dans cette équipe
de France il y avait pas la place pour
un peu Alexandre Lacazette qui a jamais
qui a jamais vraiment fait l'unanimité
en équipe de France qui a beaucoup de
mal en club Arsenal il y a vraiment des
périodes assez longues ou il ne jouait
pas alors certes là il revient bien avec
Lyon mais il part très loin pour
l'équipe de France alors après le
Nantais voici le Monégasque donc on a
parlé de gagner d'air tout à l'heure il
nous parle de dommage pour bannière
ainsi que
qu'on avait vu en équipe de France et
qui avait fait plutôt un bon match oui
qui avait été plutôt plutôt pas mal
après bah c'est un peu un peu temps
ouais c'est un peu le peut-être le
perdant finalement à ce poste là où il
passe un peu dans la hiérarchie derrière
derrière tout le monde en fait derrière
un qui pendait Varane qui sont
discutables et derrière c'est célibato
salibuage de défenseur ça peut faire un
super joueur Saliba ou pas mécano et et
Konaté qui finalement passe qui passe
qui passe devant Badi Achille il est pas
loin il est rode un petit peu et
effectivement au moindre pépin physique
c'est lui qui a appelé a priori
maintenant voilà il souffre comme
beaucoup on l'a dit de la concurrence ça
se pose là parce que dans l'absolu c'est
des défenseurs qui pourraient être
amenés à jouer dans quasiment toutes les
sélections effectivement alors on attend
toujours Didier Deschamps qui devraient
arriver dans cette salle de conférence
de presse ou les joueurs commencent à
trouver le temps long à priori mais il
devrait arriver d'ici quelques temps on
va chercher ce que vous connaissez
peut-être que vous voyez sur la chaîne
l'équipe notamment de nos collègues on
nous parle de Léo Dubois les hauts du
bois qui est parti à gatassa est-ce que
Léo Dubois on en parle plus non plus non
n'en parle plus pourtant il disait qu'il
rêvait encore un petit peu de l'équipe
de France mais effectivement à Lyon il a
il sait plus du tout lieu d'admimité il
a pas spécialement convaincu en équipe
de France maintenant ils jouent en
Turquie dans un championnat quand même
un petit peu moins relevé donc
clairement il était pas loin de la
discussion et de toute façon il y avait
des joueurs qui passaient devant lui je
pense sur ce poste de latéral droit
clairement c'était c'était il y avait
aucune chance franchement pour que du
bois soit appelé aujourd'hui le fou
Furious pourquoi on n'a pas pris Thomas
Lemar il est très efficace et
équivalent alors c'est vrai mais il joue
pas beaucoup
que il a un physique assez incertain qui
n'a pas une place de titulaire
clairement dessinée Atletico ça mérite
elle aussi qu'on commence un petit peu
tard mais on pouvait aussi en parler
c'est un joueur qui a une certaine
polyvalence qui peut jouer dans l'axe
sur un côté qui peut apporter des choses
assez différentes
maintenant on verra comment Diler les
champs dessine cette équipe de France
c'est une incertitude sur le système un
joueur un peu comme Thomas Lemar aurait
pu effectivement correspondre parce
qu'il peut combler plusieurs postes mais
encore une fois il y a tellement de
talents et d'assurance dans cette équipe
de France en attaque
encore une fois si vous voulez ajouter
un nom essayez d'enlever un en tout cas
on attaque ça me paraît quasiment
impossible allez bah on peut rajouter
Anthony martial et c'est dans le vin non
par exemple universel pareil qui n'a
jamais vraiment confirmé
non jamais confirmé en équipe de France
et à Manchester il a il a remis un peu
de nez à la fenêtre sur les derniers
matchs il a profité de certaines
absences certaines défaillances
notamment de Cristiano Ronaldo en club
il en a un petit peu profité mais c'est
encore là aussi beaucoup trop court et
beaucoup trop loin dans la course en
équipe de France encore une fois là il
faut être vraiment un taulier il faut
être un super il faut être un top joueur
en fait pour être en attaque dans cette
équipe de France
digne je vois qui Stéphane nous dit
digue mais je crois qu'il parle de Digne
elle fait des bons matchs en équipe de
France à chaque fois digne il revient de
blessures aussi c'est peut-être ça qui
rentre en compte ouais peut-être et
pourtant c'est je crois le week-end pas
le week-end dernier mais peut-être celui
plutôt d'avant où il a où il était
impressionnant contre Manchester United
il a mis un coup franc en direct il a
fait un très bon match effectivement sur
sur l'équipe de France on n'a jamais été
trop déçu finalement de Lucas Digne il
partait à priori avec une longueur
d'avance sur faire leur indice c'est les
infos qui qui fuitaient encore ce matin
et finalement il y en a aucun des deux
en équipe de France donc
on va en reparler et Didier Deschamps va
sûrement parler longuement de son
conférence de presse le choix de la
polyvalence finalement il y a qu'un seul
latérale gauche de métier dans cette
équipe c'est théorlandaise et on me
demande comment ça se fait que Jordan
vert et tout soit soit sélectionné vous
demandera les journalistes de vendredi
des champs on aura la réponse la
conférence de presse était prévu pour
21h il est 21h c'est comme vous pouvez
le voir il est important mais il va
arriver ensuite Landry qui nous parle de
mal au Gusto mal au Gusto
après
mal au Gusto latéral du côté de Lyon un
peu jeune un peu tendre mais pourquoi
pas pour plus tard oui encore jeune
encore encore encore un peu un peu
récent mais là effectivement c'est aussi
un nombre qu'on pourra romaner dans dans
les prochains mois après c'est un super
joueur c'est un super jeune très
prometteur avec Lyon et clairement la
semaine dernière il a gagné sa place
titulaire il a bien mérité et
aujourd'hui on a c'est intéressant
vraiment de suivre la progression parce
que c'est un joueur qu'on va parler
encore je pense en équipe de France
espoir et peut-être à terme encore une
fois en équipe de France parce que comme
dit tout à l'heure c'est pas des postes
finalement les latéraux s'y fournissent
ça pour le coup en équipe de France et
Eden qui nous parle des frères Thuram
Marcus et kepheren Marcus Thuram qui
joue du côté du Borussia motion glarbach
je sais jamais comment très bien le
prononcer et qui freine qui joue de qui
qui joue à Nice les deux tueurs ne sont
pas présents non plus non ils sont pas
présents pourtant Marcus Thuram avait eu
quelques sélections
après là aussi on va répéter un petit
peu la même chose mais là aussi c'est
encore un peu court c'est c'est un peu
l'équipe de France ça serait l'équipe de
France l'équipe de France B équipe de
France B il serait il y aurait pas de
problème il serait avec des martials des
Fekir c'est vrai que des super joueurs
mais il y a juste au talent en équipe de
France et qui freinerables là aussi
c'est encore un peu un peu récent un peu
léger il y a d'autres joueurs qui
passaient devant un petit peu plus
confirmé qui ont plus de vécu et à un
moment donné on peut pas prendre que des
jours à zéro sélection parce que déjà
gain Douzi vert et tout ça pas beaucoup
de sélection youssoufana non plus dans
un secteur où il y en a quand même
besoin un petit peu de vécu d'expérience
je pense que Pogba Pogba lui tout seul a
peut-être autant de sélection que les
similiothérains réunis donc clairement
un qui est frame il était loin dans dans
la hiérarchie Scott qui nous dit
truffaire pour être remplaçant on n'a
pas encore parlé derrière truffaire qui
a pourtant une sélection il me semble il
aurait pu aussi être là mais là aussi si
on n'a pas de latéral si on a pas de de
Lucas Digne ou de faire l'emendi est-ce
qu'on prend Adrien truffaire bah voilà
c'est que je pense que Adrien truffaire
il est au milieu 4e dans la hiérarchie
des latéraux gauche
là clairement je pense qu'il entrait
absolument pas dans dans l'esprit de
Deschamps clairement il y a des joueurs
qui passaient devant et même digne faire
leur Mendy parce que certainement de
vent ils ont même pas été pris donc ce
sont dit assez long sur sur le poste de
latérale gauche alors je viens de vous
remettre la liste qui avait sauté
Hitachi multiago Silva en équipe de
France vu qu'il a la double nationalité
alors les joueurs qui ont joué pour un
pays ne peuvent pas rejouer pour un
autre il me semble ouais c'est
compliment compliqué en terme de de
réglement FIFA et de toute façon je
pense que tu es aussi loin à choisir il
préfère la jouer avec le Brésil cette
année que que avec la France il a une
histoire a terminé avec le Brésil
effectivement Island Man qui nous dit
pourquoi 25 au lieu de 26 c'est vrai on
va reparler on en a parlé un peu au
début mais 25 au lieu de 26 c'est pour
pas donc il faut pas non plus qu'on soit
35 à la Coupe du monde en fait oui voilà
ça sert à rien d'emmener d'emmener non
plus 35 joueurs ou après pourquoi 25 à
26 bah ça aussi c'est certainement une
question que les gens ils se vont poser
en conférence de presse à des champs
c'est une question qui est tout à fait
légitime finalement un joueur de plus de
moins est-ce que ça fait une grosse
différence d'un autre côté on a envie de
dire bah dans ce cas pourquoi est-ce
qu'il n'a pas pris en plus mais en même
temps ce que ça va changer grand chose
est-ce que ça va changer tout le dessin
de l'équipe de France je pense pas qu'il
faudra en faire toute une histoire après
on verra peut-être faire la compétition
on se dira si seulement il y avait
Martin Terrier ou je ne sais qui
pourrait le faire rentrer qu'il ferait
basculer le badge jusqu'à Christopher
Goku après ça serait investiième joueur
qui serait plus peut-être dans l'optique
d'être vraiment là si jamais il y a des
blessés donc c'est pas un joueur
vraiment qui serait changer qui serait
amené à changer tout sauf ce fameux 26e
joueur
maintenant voilà on verra ce que nous
dira descendre nous on n'a pas la
réponse mais effectivement c'est curieux
de enfin voilà je vais peut-être un
petit peu insister mais sur tanking non
BD il a profit quand même assez
différent par rapport aux autres vidéos
de terrain pourquoi est-ce qu'il y avait
est-ce qu'il y avait pas moyen de
l'incorporer d'incorporer un joueur ce
joueur bonus en fait ce joueur un peu
Joker ce genre différent un peu des
autres mais qui qui aurait pu apporter
si vraiment besoin selon un scénario de
match qui aurait pu apporter ce truc en
plus ce truc aucun autre joueur n'aurait
d'embêlé Fekir pourquoi pas est-ce que
c'est joueur accepteraient d'être sur le
banc et de rester en retrait bon la vue
avec on l'a quand même un peu vu avec
lesquels la Coupe du Monde il a pas
jouer tant que ça il me semble non il a
pas beaucoup joué non plus effectivement
après aussi on avait parlé tout à
l'heure de faire auto vin qui il était
très souriant en dehors mais en fait il
fait très mal peut-être que Fekir
c'était pareil on sait absolument rien
maintenant effectivement il y a aussi ce
choix à un moment donné de gestion de
groupe de vécu de groupe solidaire
il y a cette question qui peut se poser
peut-être qu'au Didier Deschamps aurait
aussi pu prendre finalement dans tant
qu'à faire un joueur plus expérimenté
qui aurait apporté d'expérience au
groupe comme vient le faire Mandanda qui
est pas amené à jouer il a pas fait
chaud là on verra il s'expliquera
sûrement sur pourquoi 25 et pas 26 on
dit Saint-Maximin latéral gauche je suis
pas sûr que ça au maximum des forces
quand même pour pour le coup non je suis
pas sûr que ce soit vraiment au profil
qui intéresse d'idées on nous parle de
la croix je pense que c'est défenseur de
Wolfsburg euh la croix est pareil il
part trop loin oui il parle vraiment
vraiment de trop long parce que je sais
pas on a mentionné peut-être 10 ou 12
défenseurs sans trop de métier depuis le
début de la soirée alors que Didier
Deschamps va arriver alors juste on
avait une petite fille on nous parlait
d'une petite fille de Vial qui ne joue
plus autant assez loin on va vous
laisser avec Didier Deschamps et on
revient tout à l'heure à tout de suite
Sophie
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous donc
contrairement conférence de presse
habituelles on va pas vous vous rappeler
la liste pris connaissance que la
trouver aussi sur les sur les écrans on
va prendre directement vos questions
donc vous me faites signe
qu'on vous donne le micro vous présenter
prénom non votre média et vous poser
votre question à Didier qui répond on va
prendre une première question ici ou pas
bonsoir du Figaro est-ce que tu peux
nous expliquer pourquoi tu as pris 25
éléments dans ta liste est-ce que tu as
des doutes encore autour de Rafale
Varane et presnel kimpembe merci
le fait de prendre
25 joueurs
je considère
que nous avons assez de sécurité pour
participer et être à cette compétition
si je pensais que 24 aurait été
suffisant ou qu'il fallait 26 j'estime
que là nous avons
suffisamment de
sécurité après je me doute bien que vous
allez rentrer dans des cas particuliers
ils sont tous différents mais à partir
du moment où
les joueurs j'ai pris la décision de les
mettre dans la liste c'est qu'ils sont
censé être hâte pour le premier match
bon sens Didier Jérémy Talbot pour l'AFP
vous partirez à 25 coûte que coûte ou
est-ce que en cas de de forfait vous
pourriez être amené à diminuer le nombre
de joueurs alors je vais vous rappeler
le règlement aujourd'hui elle est
officielle mais elle sera officialisée
pour la FIFA lundi 14 à 19h elle sera
verrouillée mais avec toujours la
possibilité comme pour toutes les
équipes nationales
si des blessures nous pouvons je
pourrais changer les joueurs jusqu'à j -
de notre premier match c'est-à-dire le
21 novembre
qui a loupé pas mal de match depuis le
début de saison tout à l'heure sur TF1
tu disais peut-être qu'il se ménage lui
innovariste a démenti tout à l'heure en
conférence de presse de son côté est-ce
que tu as la certitude qu'est-ce qu'il a
bien antique que Karim semagé
la version qu'on lui donnait c'est il se
ménage pour la Coupe du Monde et carlon
de chelotti dit non si il joue pas c'est
qu'il peut pas et qu'est-ce qu'il a
exactement quelle est la nature entre
les ce qui peut être dit déclaré un faux
pas info j'ai échangé avec Karim bien
évidemment
[Musique]
pour avoir des tenants et les
aboutissants évidemment s'il est pas sur
le terrain c'est qu'il a eu un petit
souci
les staffs médicaux ont changé ensemble
il y a pas d'inquiétude par rapport
à sa situation par rapport aux échéances
qui sont qui sont les nôtres mais par
rapport à sa forme il y a pas
d'inquiétude sachant que sa dernière
titularisation ça remonte quand même au
19 octobre
après il y a ceux qui jouent trop et
après ce voilà il a eu
deux petits soucis physiques à gérer
et à l'approche par rapport à ce que
représente la Coupe du Monde
il est vigilant très très vigilant s'il
avait pu être il a fait 30 minutes
la semaine dernière il a ressenti une
gêne
le lendemain ou deux jours après
partir de là et une connaissance et pas
quelqu'un qui qui va rester sur une
table de soins certes il est pas sur le
sur le terrain parce qu'il y a pas de de
risques à prendre lui que les autres
même s'il y en a qui qui peuvent en
prendre par moment mais il y en a qui
sont en train de jouer là d'autres qui
joueront à 9h30
et il y a des matchs encore là donc mais
j'ai pas de voilà il y a pas de
d'inquiétude sur par rapport à la
semaine prochaine
j'ai pas d'éléments qui sont négatifs
par rapport à sa situation sur le plan
physique
vous avez sélectionné neuf défenseurs il
y a 8 d'entre eux qui sont des
défenseurs centraux de formation même si
on a bien sûr qu'ils peuvent évoluer au
poste de latéraux est-ce que à la
lecture de cette liste on se dirige vers
un retour potentiel à une défense à 4 et
ce que vous avez travaillé depuis un an
et ce système à 5 du coup n'est plus
forcément d'actualité en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'on peut l'interpréter au vu
de la liste je suis pas
uniquement utilisé un système
à trois donc de par la structure de la
liste
évidemment
l'option n'est pas une une défense à
trois mais ça sera une défense à 4 alors
qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir vous
donner comme comme élément évidemment
c'est une toujours une longue
réflexion a pris l'analyse de ce qu'on a
fait beaucoup de discussions avec mon
staff
mais que les joueurs parce que je
considère que le ressenti des joueurs de
certains joueurs
nourrissent ma réflexion et pour arriver
à une analyse où on a fait de bonnes
choses de très bonnes choses dans ce
système mais on a été aussi
en difficulté
on a été très souvent
même si on a renversé des situations
très compromises on a été très souvent
en déséquilibre
et je sais trop bien que pour exister
dans une grande compétition
ça va pas vous faire gagner mais si vous
êtes pas solide sur le plan de défensif
alors c'est pas au détriment de il y en
a qui peuvent être à penser qu'à
défendre maintenant il faudra bien
défendre et mieux défendre pas au
détriment de l'animation offensive mais
si je fais ces options là
en reprenant tout ce que je vous ai dit
c'est parce que je suis convaincu que
c'est mieux c'est plus adapté et donc le
système forcément malheureusement
amène à des choix qui sont dans la
structure de la liste et des choix de
joueurs qui sont différents
sur la droite bonsoir Didier droite
la chaîne équipe Didier vous allez
répéter insister sur le fait que Olivier
Giroud ne serait pas à la Coupe du monde
si Karim Benzema et Karim Mbappé était
disponible parce que j'ai dit ça non
j'ai une position par rapport à Olivier
qui est pas spécifique à Olivier a
beaucoup de joueurs qui ont statut et
c'est énorme difficulté
à accepter
alors vous pouvez penser que
voilà moi j'ai un mot qui est très
important c'est s'adapter
s'adapter c'est pas se contredire
de la réalité du moment il y a des
éléments une situation la position j'ai
pas changé de dans ma tête mais il y a
des choses qui font à travers des
discussions que j'ai avec Olivier avec
les autres joueurs les éléments
que j'ai en plus sur le terrain et en
dehors du terrain
qui m'amène à réfléchir et si je fais ce
choix là aujourd'hui
c'est parce que un j'ai confiance à
Olivier et la situation d'aujourd'hui
pour lui n'est pas la même
que
à l'été
2021 pour différentes raisons et à
partir du moment où je pense que c'est
mieux pour l'équipe de France qui soit
là j'ai une position mais je suis pas
justement qu'est-ce que concrètement
vous avez changé d'avis il faut pas ce
que je viens de te dire je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails mais évidemment
il y a des éléments à travers les
discussions que je peux avoir et avec
lui avec surtout avec lui et après les
les réponses que je des éléments que
vous vous pouvez pas avoir c'est sur le
terrain ce qui se passe mais
en interne aussi
bonsoir Didier
ça pas été la liste la plus simple à
faire pour vous non il y a eu des
joueurs qui ont eu des petits soucis
physiques il y a pas de match de
préparation est-ce que vous vous sentez
prêt à aborder cette coupe du monde dans
les meilleures conditions
qu'est-ce que c'est les meilleurs
conditions est-ce qu'on était dans les
meilleures conditions en 2018 à 2021 on
y était on était les plus beaux les plus
forts
je sais même pas si on aurait dû rentrer
sur le terrain on avait gagné tous les
matchs c'est pas passé d'une extrême
alors il y a des difficultés qui sont là
évidemment je vais pas
en faire il y a déjà deux absents de
poids avec Paul Pogba et
Ngolo Kanté oui c'est une perte bien
évidemment donc
[Musique]
on est dans une situation
difficile mais compliqué qui pour toutes
les équipes après est-ce que nous on est
plus touché que chacun aura sa propre
interprétation il y a beaucoup de
blessés il y en a un dernier hier avait
m'amené le Sénégal
il y a des joueurs qui jouent ce soir il
y en a qui jouent ce week-end et même
des joueurs qui ont pas de problème ils
peuvent avoir un souci c'est les enfants
les impondérables il y en a toujours là
on en a eu évidemment
des importants
moi j'ai confiance en ce groupe et je
suis sûr qu'il va tout faire pour voilà
livrer bataille c'est compliqué je vais
pas vous reprendre les statistiques
l'historique ou quoi que ce soit c'est
la plus grande compétition
il faudra qu'on soit à fond mais on va y
être les joueurs vont tout faire nous on
y est depuis le staff on y est depuis un
bon moment des étapes est-ce que j'ai
déjà eu à le dire c'est quoi le
révélateur pour dire comparer entre 2014
2016-2018 avant les matchs de
qualification le révélateur c'est quoi
c'est la compétition voilà et c'est pas
se dire l'objectif aujourd'hui il y a un
objectif on connaît nos trois premiers
adversaires
et l'objectif c'est
d'être dans la deuxième compétition dans
la compétition
mais
c'est pas ok on a un statut on l'a on a
même un peu plus longtemps que que
d'habitude mais ça nous donne pas de
garantie ou quoi que ce soit comme ceux
qui sont là
et qui étaient là il y a 4 ans c'est pas
arrivé comme ça
il faudra qu'on soit au maximum parce
qu'en face oui ils ont des problèmes
aussi mais il y a la qualité bien
évidemment aussi
j'ai deux questions ma première c'est
sur le plateau de TF1 vous étiez assis
optimiste vis-à-vis de cette Coupe du
Monde de ce fait pensez-vous que cette
sélection de joueurs représente la
meilleure équipe que vous avez dirigée
en équipe de France et ma deuxième
question concerne Mac million comme on
n'était pas sûr en fait de son forfait
est-ce que son absence dans cette liste
confirme qu'il est officiellement
forfait pour la Coupe du monde
alors vous m'avez trouvé optimiste moi
je suis toujours d'une philosophie
positive sans penser ne me voir arriver
avant d'y être arrivé l'énergie la
détermination elle est là je le répète
je fais confiance aux joueurs ce groupe
de 25 joueurs pour
faire face
à nos adversaires que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
et tous les matchs de très haut niveau
sont compliqués il y a 4 ans le premier
match contre l'Australie le résultat
était là mais c'était loin d'être
et puis il y en a qui peuvent bien
partir et puis après il faut il faut
voilà il faut être plus fort avoir plus
que
plus que les adversaires mais c'est pas
voilà je suis pragmatique réaliste
il y aura de la difficulté toutes les
équipes ont de la difficulté alors qu'on
soit considéré avec faisant partie des
des favoris ou pas avec les derniers
résultats
qui compte c'est ce qui nous attend et
on a peu de temps devant nous comme les
autres équipes nationales
je suis un peu surpris de la deuxième
question si évidemment magmayan n'est
pas dans dans la liste c'est que
c'est pas possible pour lui
d'être opérationnel par rapport
au délai qu'il y a et
le temps que nécessite
on ne brûlant pas les étapes sa blessure
musculaire une récidive sur un mollet
qui est toujours problématique je vais
pas aller dans le domaine médical mais
voilà nous les joueurs ils arrivent à
Clairefontaine lundi midi
on n'a pas 15 jours 3 semaines de prépa
lundi et mercredi en voyage
à Doha et dès jeudi on est focus
focus Australie
vous avez dit à juste titre qu'il y
avait des matchs ce soir ce week-end que
vous pouviez encore changer de jusqu'au
dernier je serai peut-être obligé je
laisserai pas est-ce qu'il y a une liste
de réservistes que vous avez
tous sélectionneur ça s'appelle une
présélection et je suis hiérarchie vous
avez faite
un peu trop je vous rajouterai je vous
donne un élément de plus puisque
peut-être vous n'êtes pas tous au
courant jusqu'à lundi
[Musique]
19h je peux prendre des joueurs que dans
cette liste de 55 joueurs après
je peux même en prendre
à l'extérieur
donc il y a pas des joueurs ils sont là
ils jouent jusqu'à ce weekend et en plus
en France il y a un dernier match à 21h
dimanche
il y en a certains qui sont concernés
on espère tous évidemment que l'état de
santé de Raphaël Varane et freestyle qui
me plaît leur permettront de tenir leur
poste dans quelques jours si c'est le
cas et avec le retour
je vais préciser un petit peu presnel
sera disponible pour le match du PSG ce
week-end pour Raphaël ça va dans le bon
sens lui
il jouera pas mais je le répète il
pourra être
disponible pour le le premier match ce
qui est donc une bonne nouvelle pour eux
qu'il sera peut-être un petit peu moins
pour les joueurs qui sont au même poste
on l'a dit il y a beaucoup de défenseurs
centraux dans cette liste oui mais il y
a des centraux mais que qui sont que je
considère
[Musique]
plus sur les côtés que dans l'axe bien
évidemment je pense que c'est pas
difficile de les identifier tout à fait
oui la question la question est surtout
de dire avec cette liste à 25 et donc
cette profusion de défenseur qui peuvent
y en a 8 d'habitude je peux en prendre
10 je peux en prendre de plus donc la
gestion humaine des déçus on sait que ça
a été un problème enfin une question qui
est revenue régulièrement sur le bilan
notamment de certaines compétitions
notamment du dernier Euro est-ce que
c'est une problématique de se dire qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup de déçu et de
joueurs dont il va falloir un petit peu
ce que je sais et je vous assure que
c'est humainement quelque chose qui est
pas agréable pour moi c'est que déjà là
j'ai fait beaucoup de déçu
il y a des joueurs qui sont malheureux
parce que voilà ils rêvent de la Coupe
du monde et ils y sont pas après là les
25 qui se sont tous très heureux
et ces 25 est-ce qu'ils veulent le 22
être dans le 11 mais ça sera pas
possible et donc il y a évidemment je
conseille toujours le cas avec avec mon
staff la gestion des joueurs qui jouent
peu ou pas notre juicy c'est de paires
de personnes donc
là c'est il y a moins de temps puisqu'on
n'a pas de préparation mais il y a les
matchs et évidemment pour les concernés
ça passe par du temps de jeu est-ce
qu'ils en nous rend tous dans l'idéal
oui mais j'ai pas la réponse aujourd'hui
ils sont tous dans pardon
je sais pas qui c'est qui parle
ils sont tous
au moins sur la feuille de match
parce que
à l'euro il fallait un envoyer
trois tribunes alors là vous savez que
vous êtes 24e 25e et 26e là ils sont 25
et il y a personne qui aura des numéros
attribués mais c'est pas fixe il y aura
pas lui les 24e lui il est 25e c'est pas
ce qui peut se passer j'aurais besoin de
tout le monde
bonjour Didier
[Musique]
Arthur
en mars dernier vous expliquer que
Benjamin Pavard était un joueur Dax
aujourd'hui dans une défense en trois
aujourd'hui dans cette liste on a
l'impression que c'est le seul arrière
droit
qu'attendez-vous de lui de pendant cette
transcription
votre expression elle est peut-être pas
vous votre interprétation elle est
peut-être pas partagée par tout le monde
c'est forcément
pas le seul arrière droit ou autrement
ça veut dire qu'il faut que je me fasse
un prix il y en a certains qui peuvent
considérer que Benjamin Pavard n'est pas
en arrière droit il peut jouer dans
l'axe
jouer dans le couloir 5 il a eu à jouer
évidemment c'est pas
c'est pas sa tasse de thé mais en ce qui
concerne les deux joueurs qui sont
concernés par le poste d'arrière droit
Jean de longues discussions avec eux ils
savent ce que j'attends de deux mais
comme d'autres il y en a certains qui
ont alterné qui peuvent jouer dans H qui
peuvent jouer latéraux il y en a
énormément c'est pas spécifique
en français
insister moi je du Brésil contre la
Tunisie ou parc militaou il joue arrière
droit j'allais dire c'est pas une
arrière-grand
alors combien c'est pas une arrière
droit il y a déjà joué au Barça
[Musique]
on peut continuer mais je suis pas là
pour vous convaincre mais
Didier
j'ai une question sur est-ce que le
enfin deux petites questions est-ce que
le fait d'avoir une tactique sans doute
avec quatre défenseurs
voilà
je vous confirme même si les
interprétations peuvent être différentes
partirons avec une défense à cœur alors
est-ce que c'est ça qui vous a poussé à
ne pas prendre Jonathan Claus qui est
qui était là sur les différents
rassemblements c'est la première
question et évoquer aussi et bien Jordan
verrait tout qui arrive sur cette liste
et voilà on peut dire petite surprise et
Matteo Guendouzi
surprise que des surprises pour beaucoup
non
j'ai perdu le fil Jonathan oui mais il
fait partie même s'il y a d'autres
joueurs qui sont
très déçus lui il fait partie de ce
je peux pas dire qu'ils peuvent l'être
mais j'ai bien conscience de
son immense déception j'en rajouterai un
autre Lucas Digne aussi qui a un certain
nombre de sélection je pourrais faire
pour pour atténuer mais après c'est des
choix sportifs évidemment
en ce qui concerne
Jonathan klos
le système et la
principale raison
la deuxième
alors Jordan vire tout qui a une
surprise bon il était quand même au
dernier ensemblement avec nous il
faisait partie aussi où il est rentré
même si c'est pas beaucoup de temps mais
dans le fin d'effort où nous avons battu
la Belgique et l'Espagne
il est déjà venu avec nous il a eu
un passage
un peu plus
compliqué à la Roma il est venu à
Marseille
au départ c'était pas mais il a retrouvé
un
très très bon niveau
après c'est concurrences au poste profil
Matteo est avec nous
assez régulièrement il peut
être utilisé dans dans différents postes
aussi avec un certain où il est un peu
plus performant que d'autres mais
[Musique]
ça amène
les garanties suffisantes
à mes yeux
oui vous avez souvent expliqué que le
système A3 derrière permettait de mettre
Antoine Griezmann qui vient de Mbappe et
Karim Benzema dans leur meilleur
opposition devant
à 4 vous allez vous organiser comment
devant là vous m'en demandez trop je
vous répondez pas et ce qui va aller sur
un côté c'est une option il y en a
d'autres
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
comment on jouera et comment enfin
conditions qui se passe rien de
négatif comment on débutera mais bon il
y a des adversaires aussi
je sais pas si vous me donnez autant
d'informations sur mes adversaires je
serai ravi mais on va faire je vais
faire en sorte d'aller les chercher
quand même mais il y a différentes
options dans l'idéal c'est vrai je l'ai
dit c'est de mettre
tous les joueurs
dans la meilleure position mais il y a
des situations où c'est pas des
positions avec le ballon sans le ballon
[Musique]
quelques petites modifications que ça
soit
sur le début ou en cours de match aussi
parce que
il y a évidemment une variété
de joueur sur le plan offensif qui sont
très intéressantes
bonsoir Didier
oui ou en bas à droite
une question un peu globale qui va
peut-être un peu brutale mais est-ce
qu'on peut être champion du monde avec
un milieu de terrain qui a aussi peu de
références internationales et aussi peu
de d'expérience et autant de jeunesse
j'ai pas la réponse personne peut la
voir
c'est la réalité
après je veux pas en rajouter non plus
parce que j'ai confiance en ces jours là
vous savez les deux joueurs qui sont pas
là ce qui représentent en termes de
d'expérience de vécu de de leadership
expressif ou plus
terrain
heureusement malgré tout que
[Musique]
dans les différentes rassemblements
qu'on a eu ces joueurs là ont eu quand
même du temps de jeu
ça va pas arriver à leur donner
évidemment
l'expérience que peuvent cumuler Paul et
Angie mais c'est toujours ça
voilà après j'ai confiance en eux et
il faut rendre tout
qui soit pas au niveau aujourd'hui de ce
que sont ils se sont pas fait du jour au
lendemain ou pas les et Angie
[Musique]
l'habitude l'expérience que ces deux
joueurs ont accumulé depuis
Paul c'est depuis le départ
pour certains c'est la première grande
compétition voilà mais ça a été le cas
aussi sur de postes spécifiques avec
Benjamin Pavard et Lucas Andernos en
2018 mais qui sont habitués c'est des
joueurs qui sont habitués au niveau
aiguiser après si je l'ai choisi c'est
parce que je pense qu'il y a le
potentiel après il y a d'autres éléments
c'est le mérite des joueurs eux d'être à
ce niveau-là sans avoir et ils ont
besoin d'être d'être encadré aussi c'est
pour ça que
d'avoir dans le groupe des cadres qui
ont vécu
c'est quelque chose de l'essentiel
[Musique]
d'abord les concernés avant de vous le
savent pas ils le savent pas encore non
et pourquoi avoir appelé donc Mandanda
qui donc en lui et place de Meignan qui
était pas forcément là dans tous les
rassemblements précédents non
pourquoi est-ce que c'est un joueur
d'expérience alors
si je vous réponds je vais au bout de la
réponse je veux répondre à la première
question donc ça va pas le faire ça va
pas le faire mais
voilà Steve
[Musique]
a fait en sorte de continuer à être
compétitif il prolonge puisque il a des
années des expériences aussi et on peut
pas gommer comme ça sur une compétition
il y a le le potentiel mais après comme
ça a été aussi
le cas pour Alphonse quand il le veut
jouer
Mike avec tout ce qui pouvait dégager
et il a souvent même si je lui ai donné
un petit peu de temps de jeu en juin là
il a la possibilité de faire les deux
matchs en septembre
il se blesse c'est physique et ce qui a
un aspect psychologique certainement
aussi quoi donc mais il y aura une
hiérarchie forcément
c'est quelque chose qui est important
j'ai à moitié répondu
le plus c'est but son état d'esprit et
concernant mes nièce j'ai rebondies ce
que vous avez dit c'est à dire que
peut-être le fait de pouvoir être
deuxième gardien de l'équipe de France
pour un coupe du monde la peut-être
conditionner psychologiquement c'est ça
qui vous dites
je parlais juste de Mike par rapport au
fait il a été il avait le rôle de numéro
2 il a eu
deux matchs à jouer en juin
c'est important pour lui aussi
d'accumuler un peu plus d'espérance il
est souvent venu avec nous mais Hugo a
joué beaucoup beaucoup de matchs et là
le fait où il a pu il allait jouer les
deux matchs puisque Hugo était blessé et
malheureusement il se blesse donc c'est
une donnée aussi même si certains
joueurs peuvent en parler
ça me rajeunit un petit peu quand
j'étais
entraîneur en club que je disais le
poids du maillot mais entre vouloir y
être tout faire pour y être quand vous y
êtes et vous êtes sur le terrain et il
s'en passe des choses être
alors il y en a ça se passe
sans souci il y en a d'autres mais il
faut gérer un peu l'aspect émotionnel et
qui a un impact sur le mais c'est pas ça
qui il a eu un problème physique ça
aurait pu lui arriver à notre moment
malheureusement ça lui arrivait avec
Milan à la reprise il fait rechute donc
voilà Olivier Giroud
non non les buts bon après non je vais
pas dire que ça me fait rire parce que
depuis le rassemblement de de septembre
on peut pas dire que le mois qui a suivi
il a été très performant en termes
d'efficacité donc même si peut-être
c'est passé un peu plus on était vous
étiez je vais pas vous critiquer loin de
là plus sévère à des moments où
il était peut-être aussi ou plus
performant qu'il aimait débute tant
mieux pour lui mais c'est pas je voulais
dire tout honnêteté vous me croyez vous
me croyez pas je vais pas acté et c'est
pas que vous faites campagne ou quoi que
ce soit c'est la clé depuis un bon
moment un bon moment avant qu'il ait
fait même quand il était moins bien même
si ça monte des buts
d'ailleurs il faut pas qu'il marque trop
parce qu'ils prennent les cartons rouges
mais je pense qu'avec avec l'expérience
il va arriver à mieux gérer ces
situations
bonsoir Didier mais je lui fais
confiance
ça il le sait
surtout
terrain et en dehors du terrain
bonsoir Didier c'est la camarade de foot
oui vous avez 8 joueurs qui peuvent
jouer à l'axe dans cette liste
il y en a qui je rends sur les côtés
d'autres qui vont jouer sur le côté
de ce jeune joueur là qui va jouer sa
première Coupe du Monde ma deuxième
question Eduardo camavinga toute la
journée il y avait des rumeurs comme
quoi il sera dans la liste où il sera
pas dans la liste est-ce que à la
dernière minute vous avez hésité à le
prendre
on va passer par la première
[Musique]
hibou
fait partie des des jeunes défenseurs
mais bon il a eu malheureusement
de blessures une un peu longue
et puis après il a été freiné de nouveau
bien évidemment mais on
n'est pas assez tâche là
titulaire à Liverpool champion d'Europe
par hasard alors il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de de bons joueurs de jeunes
joueurs défenseurs certains sont là
d'autres
sont pas là
minuit potentiellement
il a beaucoup de de qualité dans sa
capacité non il a un jeu de je déteste
qui est de grandes qualités il est bon
dans le duel il va vite
il est plutôt à droite avec le ballon
où je voulais pas dans une équipe top
niveau européen comme il l'a fait
si tôt sans avoir évidemment d'énormes
qualités
la deuxième éduardo alors moi j'écoute
pas les rumeurs autrement je pense que
je prendrai les tubes d'aspirine tous
les jours
[Musique]
je vais pas rentrer dans le
dans le secret par rapport aux
discussions que je peux avoir avec les
joueurs
Edouardo est depuis
plusieurs années mais quand il est venu
avec nous il a tout de suite montré des
choses
très intéressantes après ça a été plus
compliqué les dans un club où il y a
beaucoup de concurrence
il est souvent utilisé en tant que joker
à différents
postes évidemment de de ce qui le le
pénalisé
de pas avoir
plus de temps de jeu régulièrement mais
il est au Real Madrid et le Real Madrid
voilà c'est de d'autres dans des clubs
peut-être
un peu moins
huppé et là il a que des internationaux
en face de lui et c'est pas des
internationaux qui ont dit souvent
sélection
mais malgré tout voilà
il se passe quelque chose quand il est
sur le terrain il fait pas tout bien
après il peut être utilisé à différents
postes il aura peut-être des préférences
comme d'autres en des préférences entre
la préférence et la réalité voilà c'est
plutôt un avantage aussi d'avoir cette
polyvalence polyvalente et ajouter à ça
l'état d'esprit de grande qualité
si quelqu'un qui a toujours le sourire
qui est très communicatif qui à l'écoute
mais je le prends pas pour ça
c'est en plus de tout ce que je viens de
dire avant quoi
alors on peut faire dire un peu ce qu'on
veut aux statistiques mais tout le monde
il y en a une cassé parlante sur les
trois dernières éditions de la Coupe du
Monde en 2010 en 2014 et en 2018 à
chaque fois le tenant du titre a été
éliminé dès la phase de poules vous
pouvez remonter bien plus loin je pense
effectivement alors comment on fait pour
que la malédiction ne tombe pas sur les
cas je ne sais pas un tube d'astérine
d'aspirine de plus c'est ça vous voulez
me saper le moral quoi
les statistiques elles sont là de toute
façon un moment c'est en fait pour être
ça montre bien
de gagner c'est très très difficile de
se maintenir salé
encore plus
il y en a qu'un qui gagne tous les
quatre ans et ici il y a c'était
historique là c'est que ça vient de
confirmer mais c'est pas ça je vais pas
partir avec ça dans la tête pour ceux
qui me connaissent
on y va avec et on va y aller mais pas
en mode
on se la raconte on est les champions du
monde c'est pas comme ça que on va
aborder la compétition parce qu'on aura
de la difficulté
en sorte de tout faire pour être le plus
performant
est-ce que c'est pareil aussi au niveau
de tes attaquants et est-ce que pour toi
finalement tu pars avec tes trois
habituels ou la concurrence est vraiment
ouverte en attaque
je discute je discute quand j'ai besoin
de discuter quand il sort avec moi des
fois ça se fait à distance aussi
je sais très bien il y a l'instant T à
chaque fois et c'est normal comme avec
mon stage je suis dans l'analyse en
tenant compte du contexte du rapport de
force mais voilà ce qui était
la vérité de septembre c'est pas celle
de de
juin et c'est passé voilà s'il faut
prendre un autre exemple qui vient dans
ce sens là et je vais pas en faire parce
que mon ami italien regardez l'Italie
c'est la référence en été et puis alors
c'était les meilleurs et après c'est
quoi
comme quoi oui c'est dur pour tout le
monde et un moment si on n'est pas ce
qu'il faut et même en même temps ce
qu'il faut parce qu'en fait il y a aussi
beaucoup de de
qualité donc
c'est les exigences du très haut niveau
ici oui deux petites questions
avec ce retour du à une défense A4
est-ce que tu pourrais considérer
Antoine Griezmann comme un milieu
relayeur
et la deuxième question c'est est-ce que
Raphaël Varane va toucher le ballon on
va reprendre l'entraînement avec le
ballon avant que la fontaine
il a déjà repris l'entraînement avec
l'autre
infos
[Musique]
je sais qu'il y a des
liaisons directes des fois un petit peu
mais avant d'arriver à ces décisions là
il y a un suivi quotidien il y a des
échanges sur le plan médical
Cyril moine qui est là
c'est déplacer aussi pour avoir le
contenu ce qui se fait et
ça continue il y a des il y a des jours
donc on sait où ils en sont et
la progression qui a
tu peux nous dire
aujourd'hui mais il est dans une phase
de réathétisation ou évidemment il est
sollicité
avec
course après on va pas rentrer dans ça
va être du chinois un petit peu en fin
de chinois pas faire de
très important pas trop compréhensible
pour tout le monde avec après c'est
intensité charge mais
retoucher le ballon et c'est censé aller
on sait ce qu'il va faire demain ce qui
va faire après-demain et pour il y a des
délais après on n'est pas là pour passer
de 0 à 70 ou 80
mais il y a des étapes à franchir
déjà
[Musique]
sur Antoine le fait qu'il soit milieu
scientifique les conséquences de ce que
je vais répondre il est
Antoine et dans un rôle offensif mais il
a cette capacité à avoir un gros volume
de jeu
même quand il est offensif ça n'empêche
pas de revenir très bas des fois trop
par moments à mon goût dans son club il
le fait aussi par moment il change de
position il se retrouve
dans un triangle
du milieu terrain soit au début soit en
cours de match
ça vous pose pas de de
problème après c'est un équilibre
[Musique]
on a parlé plutôt des latéraux droit
est-ce qu'on pourrait parler des
latéraux gauche et qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à privilégier les frais
hollandaise le casse et Théo plutôt que
de prendre Lucas Digne et faire le lundi
c'est une question de concurrence
de parce que le cas c'était au fond non
pas que
Lucas et Ferland
ne font pas des choses bien mais dans
deux profils différents bien évidemment
mais
si je fais ce choix là c'est parce que
bien évidemment
je considère qu'ils apportent
plus de garanties dans une concurrence
par rapport aux deux autres joueurs
et on va terminer cette conférence de
presse avec
Sophie a d'autres questions et tu vois
c'est Didier évidemment mais ça ira
alors avec Bertrand Latour de la chaîne
l'équipe
de question vous avez souvent dit vous
aviez des réticents sur le feu d'aligner
4 jours à vocation offensive au début
d'un match de très haut niveau
est-ce que vous êtes toujours sur ce
logiciel là ou sur d'autres sujets
l'équilibre est plus aléatoire donc non
je dis pas que c'est pas sur 90 minutes
ça peut être
une option à un moment mais pour exister
ou alors il faut qu'on fasse on aura pas
d'époux en face c'est pas la Playstation
ok c'est bien beau et c'est pas souvent
j'ai eu à le dire parce que ça a pu
m'arriver non pas pour vous convaincre
vous vous prouver que
voilà si tu as le ballon tu as pas de
souci
pas de souci mais un moment si tu l'as
pas
faut être capable de
résoudre aussi l'équilibre
l'équilibre défensif ça peut ça peut
mais c'est pas parce que tu mets plus
d'attaquant que tu vas marquer plus de
buts
et comme
pas faire le professeur je suis loin
d'un écran
des fois tu as trois occasions tu as
marqué trois buts des fois tu en as 8
étant ta mère
après c'est une question de d'efficacité
dans l'équilibre ça amène je répète avec
le ballon oui ça donne de la variété
tout ça mais
quand tu l'as pas l'équilibre forcément
il est
plus compliqué
à l'instant la polyvalence et
l'éventuelle dépassement de fonction au
sujet d'un point de Griezmann est-ce que
pour Adrien rabiot on peut aussi
s'attendre à un poste évolutif un peu
comme Blaise Matuidi il avait eu déjà
fait
à la Juventus de Turin il a joué dans
différents postes mais ça fait depuis un
bon moment autant avant il était plus
lui même il se limitait par rapport à sa
position qui avait une j'ai envie de par
son épanouissement
la main avoir une palette
plus large j'aime bien
oui la formule qu'il a utilisé pour se
définir c'est définir un joueur
d'équilibre
ça peut-être pas trop de valeur
[Musique]
ça a beaucoup de valeur et pour en
sélectionneur aussi
[Musique]
lundi vous retrouver Didier Deschamps et
un joueur à 16h en conférence de presse
c'est l'entraînement est ouvert
pareil mardi
bonne soirée merci
et bien voilà nous venons d'entendre au
lit Didier Deschamps voilà Didier
Deschamps sur cette conférence de presse
dis les gens qui étaient assez en forme
on l'a senti il avait envie d'être un
peu dur sur l'homme voilà de faire
quelques petites blagues aux
journalistes a priori ouais ouais il
était assez prince décembre en tout cas
il est plein d'énergie et faudra bien
dilier des champs plein d'énergie pour
pour la Coupe du monde en plus
sérieusement on va parler un peu de ce
qu'il a raconté il y a quand même une
information principale de cette
conférence de presse c'est qu'on va
jouer à 4 derrière c'est sûr et certain
voilà il l'a assumé c'est pas étonnant
parce que la liste est clairement faite
pour ça je pense tous compris il y avait
pas vraiment de secret
voilà qui descend il assumait il
annonçait ça jouera quatre derrière ça
jouera pas à 5
après on avait parlé tout à l'heure
avant la conférence de presse que c'est
pas impossible non plus de jouer à 5
avec cette équipe c'est pas impossible
la liste n'est pas fait pour ça mais
c'est pas infaisable sur une cour de
séquence sur un match sur une mi-temps
c'est pas impossible peut-être que
Didier Deschamps le fera peut-être qu'il
joue aussi un petit peu la tox on va en
reparler mais il a joué davantage
l'intox il a davantage voulu garder les
secrets sur sur d'autres aspects de son
jeu ouais il a un peu donné le côté
défenseur pour qu'on lui pour qu'il soit
tranquille on va dire sur les autres
plantes totalement sur l'attaque et le
milieu la dernière question était quand
même assez intéressante sur Adrien
rabiot on se rappelle Blaise Matuidi qui
était dans un rôle alors il y avait deux
milieux à la Coupe du Monde et un Blaise
Matuidi latéral qui revenait un peu
milieu on pourrait attendre la même
chose du côté d'Adrien rabiot c'est ça
c'est qu'on avait un peu un système en
quatre deux trois un et que dans le dans
les trois qui sont censés être des jours
offensif bah en fait on avait un Blaise
Matuidi qui était à profit clairement
plus défensif et presque 4 de 3 un peu 4
3 3 finalement c'était pas un cadre 3
aussi traditionnel aussi offensif que ça
pourrait l'être en théorie peut-être que
c'est ce vers quoi va s'orienter Didier
Deschamps et ça expliquerait en partie
pourquoi 6 milieux de terrain peut-être
que un de ces milieux de terrain
en fait un petit peu plus haut dans
l'optique d'avoir plus d'équilibre aussi
cher à Didier Deschamps ce sera
peut-être dans cette optique et
effectivement là dans cette optique je
pense que Adrien rabiot apparaît être le
profil le plus apte et du coup ça
pourrait imaginer un duo au milieu
peut-être choix mini Fofana ça pourrait
se dessiner comme ça pour avoir une
équipe de France plus équilibrée dans
une défense A4 donc on serait sur ce qui
ressemblait déjà du côté de l'équipe de
France en 2018 avec on l'a dit
une attaque finalement
Benzema Mbappé Griezmann et ravi d'un
côté c'est ça ça sera ça sera un petit
peu ça après avoir comment ça
s'articulerait en principe rabio
j'aurais à gauche et est-ce que ça veut
dire que j'aurai à droite
il faut aussi les faire jouer cette
attaquant qu'on a fait ça il faut
réussir à aller aller faire jouer
ensemble en tout cas ce trio là devant
Benzema Papili Griezmann il paraît
indissociable et c'est quand un gros
enjeu pour Didier les gens de réussir à
bien les faire jouer ensemble il suffit
pas de les mettre sur le terrain et leur
dire de se débrouiller et il faut que
tout c'est un brique un peu ensemble
maintenant voilà on va assez vite quand
même se projeter sur la défense A4 ce
qui paraît assez assez dur quand même
assez terrible pour cette équipe de
France c'est que ça faisait plus d'un an
que l'équipe de France travaille avec
une défense à 5 que finalement Didier
Deschamps clairement renoncé aujourd'hui
sur un an sur ce qu'on a vu sur la
défense A5 pour lui le constat est clair
ça n'a pas marché c'est un échec et
aujourd'hui l'abandonne on retourne
avant il a été aussi pas mal interrogé
sur les défenseurs alors on l'a dit il a
choisi son système par contre lui a posé
la question il y a quand même pas mal de
défenseurs il y en a 9 il y en a 8 qui
sont sans trop c'est ça c'est qu'on a en
fait aparté au Hernandez qui est
clairement latérale gauche tous les
autres défenseurs donc il y a 8
défenseurs qui peuvent potentiellement
jouer dans l'axe et c'est tous en fait
leur même leur poste de prédilection
leur poste de métier après évidemment
Benjamin Pavard est dédié au poste de
latéralement en équipe de France ça
c'est clair et net il y a pas de
discussion je le Condé peut dépanner à
droite Lucas Hernandez peut dépanner à
gauche donc les postes sont quand même
plutôt doublés ça il y a pas de problème
maintenant
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure il avait
fait il avait fait le choix de la
polyvalence il a fait le choix de la
polyvalence il s'est passé de latéraux
de métier avec Lucas Dean faire
c'est plus un piston de métier c'est
encore un petit peu différent mais il a
fait ce choix fort peut-être notamment
du coup parce que ici il dit maintenant
pas de défense à 5 c'est à dire que
finalement n'a plus ou moins rien à
faire dans cette c'est un peu ça c'est
un peu ça c'est que dans une défense A4
on considère que Jonathan close comme il
n'a jamais joué dans une défense A4 au
niveau en Ligue 1 ou en équipe de France
il n'a absolument pas les repères pour
ça c'est un autre système ça demande
d'autres choses d'autres qualités et
Didier Deschamps peut pas partir avec
Jonathan close qui devrait jouer un
nouveau rôle qui ne me connaît
absolument pas qui n'a pas appréhendé en
équipe de France une dernière petite
question peut-être sur Olivier Giroud
puisque
on a parlé mais avec une petite boutade
en disant qu'il fallait qu'il ait un peu
plus d'expérience à certains moments
il sera là
un peu en super sub dans ce rôle de de
remplaçant de Karim Benzema avoir
comment est-ce que ça peut s'articuler
est-ce que on aura souvent un changement
Giroud Benzema alors 70ème minute
quelque chose comme ça est-ce que est-ce
que ça peut s'articuler différemment
aussi on parlait de la possibilité que
ce soit un quête de 3 avec radio qui
joue dans les fameux trois donc ça pose
qui est censé être offensif mais bon on
veut garder un petit peu l'équilibre il
y a une possibilité pour que rabiot
sorte en cours de match et que ce soit
un vrai entre guillemets offensif qui
rentre et qu'à ce moment-là dit les
champs lâche un petit peu les chevaux
selon le scénario du match l'équipe de
France qui serait menée ou quoi qui
permet peut-être d'offrir pas mal de
solutions comme ça ensuite en
remplacement et l'équipe de France sur
le front de l'attaque ça veut dire qu'on
partirait avec Ousmane Dembélé en
plaçant Olivier Giroud même qui se fait
quand même Christopher un coucou c'est
des joueurs qui peuvent vraiment changer
le cours d'un match c'est des joueurs
qu'on n'attendra pas mal en sortie de
banc on verra effectivement alors j'ai
ceci fait une dernière question parce
qu'on est parlé aussi c'est sur les
gardiens les gardiens là hiérarchie
n'est pas très clair mais elle est quand
même un peu Hugo Lloris numéro un et
après c'était pendant l'areola on a
quand même à peu près compris qui était
le numéro 2 voilà on a un peu compris
parce que Didier Deschamps vous voulez
pas le l'avouer et en même temps quand
tu l'as demandé pourquoi je suis
Mandanda il a dit le choix de
l'expérience
clairement mon mandat vient en numéro 3
je pense que c'est assez clair même si
des gens a reconnu qu'il a un peu
répondu à la question sans vouloir y
répondre
finalement donc mignon est absent l'idée
c'est de pas pas d'avoir un troisième
gardien comme Alban Lafont qui viendrait
du coup vraiment jouer ce rôle au cas où
Lloris et Areola ne sont finalement pas
disponibles c'est de se dire bon
normalement il y aurait jouera s'il y a
vraiment un gros problème bon bah ce
sera au tour d'aréola de le suppléer et
Mandanda sauf catastrophe absolue il
jouera pas il est avant tout pour
apporter son expérience pour apporter ce
vécu à une équipe de France qui connaît
depuis presque 15 ans maintenant et avec
lequel il était déjà champion du monde
comme remplaçant et puis on verra ça
pour le début de la Coupe du Monde c'est
prévu le 22 vous le savez c'est le
premier match contre l'Australie le 26
ce sera le Danemark et le 30 ce sera la
Tunis vous pourrez le suivre bien sûr en
direct sur le Figaro on se mobilise il y
aura des émissions spéciales on sera sur
place également je serai sur place avec
Christophe remise ainsi que Baptiste
Després et d'ailleurs on vous fera vivre
la conférence de presse de lundi il a
dit voter un tour de 16h de Didier
Deschamps merci beaucoup Sébastien merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous merci
à vous d'avoir été très nombreux à nous
suivre et on vous dit à bientôt pour de
nouveaux live sur figarolive